On that.
Right when we go live,
dad
is over 10,000 Viking fans with the
Viking clap there.
Icelandic fans
and that is uh,
a coordinated clap.
There could not be done.
The United States of America,
ladies and gentleman,
we got a little too much independence.
Thank you know going on over here.
Can you imagine if we can we have that
kind of organization?
We could do a clap in America.
Clap.
Awesome.
Okay.
A group Haka.
Why can't we do that?
How can we watch the Haka we watched
like those awesome Samoan dudes.
Are They Samoan that are doing that?
That is New Zealand.
New Zealand.
Yeah.
That is one of the dopest fucking ward
dances the world's ever known and it's
going on right now.
Like it's not some Viking shit that they
forgot about did.
They probably used to do,
but everybody who did it got slaughtered
or died off or they didn't tell their
grandchildren because I didn't want him
carrying on the way.
This is some real shit.
They're doing it right now at a soccer
game.
Soccer's we're placing more,
right?
Yeah.
This is going on.
It's a good chance for your country to
go fuck up another country.
Yeah.
And you,
uh,
nobody has to die.
You still get to do the war cry.
Yeah.
Mike Schmidt
and the ladies and gentlemen pull this
straight up man.
Oh,
okay.
So,
uh,
let me tell everybody how this podcast
got started and why I'm,
why I wanted to talk to you cause I'm,
Mike Works,
the comedy store,
uh,
seemed like very cool guy and a one day
we're hanging out in the back patio and
you know,
like,
uh,
all the employees of the comedy store,
it's like kind of a hang,
you know,
it's an interesting place to work,
right?
Yeah.
It's just to hang.
And during the course of a,
this hang you started telling me about
your past before you worked at the
comedy store and uh,
you started telling me some really
disturbing shit that you saw in the
criminal justice system while while you
were working there.
And I was like,
this is a fascinating subject and uh,
let's,
let's talk about it on a podcast.
So here we are.
Yep.
I figured why not?
It's fucked up so I may as well tell
people.
Yeah.
Will you tell him so much?
He did for 10 years,
so I was a criminal defense attorney for
about 10 years.
I was for the first year or two in
central Wisconsin and then I moved down
to Dane County,
Wisconsin,
which is where Madison is,
you know,
University of Wisconsin,
all that fun stuff.
It's the capital of the state.
Shout out to my friend Doug during
powerful.
Doug Darren.
Yeah,
he lives there.
Yeah.
It's a great comedy club.
Yes it does.
It really does.
It's an awesome town.
It's a very liberal town,
very liberal town.
And you would think that because it's
very liberal that black people are
treated well there and it is absolutely
not the case.
It is the like if you're black in
America,
I mean you've seen the studies,
you've seen the statistics,
you've seen riots,
like things are not good,
you're not being treated well.
And you would think that the worst place
to be would be where you see riots
happening like Ferguson,
but actually it's Madison,
Wisconsin,
no place our black people more poor in
relation to the white people around them
than Madison,
Wisconsin.
No.
Where else do black children get
arrested more often in comparison with
white children then Madison,
Wisconsin.
You would think at Birmingham,
Alabama.
You would think,
where are those pictures that I saw
people getting hoses turned on him or
dog sent home.
I bet that's where they treat black
folks like,
Shit.
No,
it's Madison,
Wisconsin.
What do you,
what do you think is causing that mean?
Why is this one area in your assessment
from working there for 10 years?
I'm like,
why is it like this?
There's,
well,
the,
I mean there's a ton of different
factors and all the factors boiled down
to racism.
Uh,
I know it's kind of condescending for me
to be a white guy from the midwest.
Colin racism on everybody,
but I'm just going to tell you what I've
observed and you know what the numbers
show because the thing is that you can't
argue with this statistics.
If this ever came down to an argument
about whether or not these numbers are
fair,
these people are being treated fairly.
We know where they are,
you know they're,
they're in prison.
We can point to the actual people.
They could raise their hands if they
wanted to and say,
but I'm sorry.
I think really what's important,
one of the things you pointed out was in
specific crimes where a white guy and a
black guy with no record did the exact
same thing.
The difference in punishment between the
white car,
the black guy,
because this is so if you want to count
numbers of people that have been
arrested,
I think there's a possibility that it
runs into that quagmire.
Well,
you know how many black people are
there,
how many white people are there?
Where's the,
are they in bad neighborhoods where
these things are taking place?
But what you're talking about is the
exact same crime.
Yup.
So you can really,
did you really see the obvious contrast?
Yeah.
Um,
the best example is burglary.
So burglary's a crime that there's
multiple stages to burglary.
Uh,
there's people who are very good at
burglary who will,
you know,
knock on a house and announced
themselves,
say eight cathy,
just to try and avoid being charged with
burglary under the statute.
Just the way it's worded.
But teenagers do burglary at different
way.
They wait until somebody is out of town
that they know,
uh,
and they robbed their parents' house and
they'll take their playstations and
they'll take their liquor and everything
and they get caught.
They'll usually do a couple of them and
they'll get caught in a group.
And if that's your first trip into the
justice system,
you are probably in Dane County,
you're probably going to get a deferred
prosecution agreement.
And if you keep your nose clean,
you'll get an expunction,
which is where the judge says,
I don't think the community would be
harmed.
And I think you would be helped by
making it.
Like this never happened.
So the police can keep a report of it,
but nobody will ever know.
So
the black kids don't get the offer of
expunction right out of the gates the
the white kids do.
And then when they fuck up and they do
because they are 19 and a lot of the
white kids are doing or stealing for
heroin,
um,
you know,
like,
I don't want to sensationalize it not,
but as to what you do.
So they'll steal for that.
They'll get popped again or they'll get
popped for curfew.
And now the deferred prosecution
agreement is polled and so they're
technically convicted of a felony.
At that point,
the white kids will still have options
of saying like,
let me give this another shot.
I'll plead to more offenses,
I'll plead the more the bail jumpings
let's haggle,
let's tag along what we're going to do.
Because they've already entered a
conviction or entered a plea on the
record to the felony for burglary.
So they still have options.
And at the end of it,
they're going to get probation.
They'll,
they might get six months conditional
time in jail,
but they're going to get probation.
And the black kids who fuck up the same
way,
who were charged with the same offense.
In my experience and what I mean what
everybody else notices.
They go to prison,
they just off to prison.
So white burglars in there early,
you know,
late teens,
early twenties,
conviction,
deferred prosecution,
possibility of expunction then still
fuck up.
And then they get probation,
black kids,
one chance prison,
and once they go to prison,
you don't really get out of that system
very long because they just keep
catching you up on probation or parole
violations.
And so that's just one example where
same number of convictions,
you know,
whether or not it's a kid with no
convictions are a bunch of convictions.
The determining factor was the race of
the kid because they're both poor.
You know,
the white burglar defendants and the
black burglar defendants are generally
both poor because if your parents have
money,
you just pay the restitution and you
kind of walk,
whoa.
Not In every case,
but when there's money over the barrel,
when you can pay the restitution in a
criminal case,
it's such a rare thing that the
prosecution will bend over backwards to
help you get that money to the people
that you fucked over.
And that's all they would have to do is
pay the equal amount.
And they could skate.
No,
no,
they don't skate completely.
But since so few people ever get their
money back from the prosecuted,
you know from the prosecution and the
crime,
anytime you can put the money up they
will bend over backwards for me.
So for a theft case in like,
like that,
yeah,
you could conceivably not be punished
for breaking into someone's house and
stealing something if you pay them for
it back.
Yeah.
If you could act a breaking in,
you won't be penalized for that.
That seems crazy.
Well,
I mean if you can pay for it,
like think I put yourself in the shoes
of a prosecutor where day in day out you
convict people crimes and you give them
time.
But then there's these victims and all
they ever get to do is read a report.
All they ever get to do is sit in a
chair and say,
you really screwed me on this one day.
And then a lot of times the defendant
doesn't even fucking look at them.
And so they never get to come with a win
for their victims and paying restitution
is a win for the victims.
Right.
So you can't ignore that.
No.
I mean I totally get it from a rational
sense,
but it just seems fucked.
I mean that literally is buying your way
out of jail.
If you look at the,
yeah,
if you look at the difference between
someone who figures out a way to come up
with the money to pay for it or they
have the money to pay for and they were
just stealing for a kick or just to be a
piece of shit versus someone who has no
money.
The only difference being is that the
one person is able to come up with some
cash.
That's,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
But of course if you're,
I mean,
the thing is if the charges are already
filed,
you're going to have to plead to
something.
Are you going to have to do a deferred
prosecution agreement?
But they'll make it as as easy as
possible.
So when you were working there and you
observe this,
I mean,
you were there for 10 years doing this,
when did it really start to sink in that
this was sort of an impossible system
and you didn't want to be a part of it?
Uh,
there.
So in order to combat,
uh,
I guess the view that people were
becoming increasingly more violent,
Dane county did this thing called the
Special Investigations Unit and the
Special Investigations Unit was
supposedly a race blind selection of the
10 most dangerous,
uh,
individuals in Dane county most likely
to re offend and hurt somebody else.
And they staffed it with the Department
of Justice and probation and parole and
some other people that we didn't know
that they staffed it about.
Um,
and so they just discussed these issues
and the sheriff's department and the US
Attorney's office and the,
and they made the list of these people
that they thought were the most
dangerous in Dane County.
And then they summoned them all to a
meeting where they threatened him and
they said,
hey,
if you,
if you step out of line,
we're going to fucking max you out on
everything.
So if you spit on the sidewalk ticket,
if you disorderly conduct,
we're going to hit you with disorderly
conduct as a repeater and try to throw
you in prison for it.
So you cock off even a little bit.
You're taking the ride.
And also,
by the way,
we have some services.
So here's a place where you can apply
for a job.
And they were all black.
That was when I knew there was no
fucking point to this because in Dane
county,
there are like 4.6% of the population or
something is black.
They can't all like the top 10 most
dangerous people in Dane county are not
all black.
I know this because some of the most
dangerous people in Dane county where my
other clients and they're white and I
was like,
I looked at the list,
I'm like,
I got other guys that belong on this
list.
I had a number of people on the list
when it first came out.
And then when they redid the list,
I had a couple more.
And when they redid the list with a new
10,
all black.
So I know black people are not evil.
I know they're normal.
I know they're just like everybody else.
How are they,
you know,
it's cause it's white or black.
The coin flip,
white or black.
They're telling me it came up 20 times
in a row on heads.
Like random chance doesn't even account
for this.
There's no race blind way to they.
And they told me afterwards,
they're like,
no,
we did it in a race blind way.
There's no way you did.
You might have thought you did.
So the system doesn't even understand
how racist it is.
How could they say they're doing it in a
race blind way?
Um,
I mean if you legitimately think through
are more dangerous people that were
working under you or that were um,
being represented by you rather.
Why,
I mean,
what was their criteria?
What were they judging on?
There was a judging on how many
convictions the violence of the
conviction.
Like what,
what were the criteria?
Well,
it was just a,
yeah,
number of convictions and offense
severity.
It's,
they,
they try a lot to figure out a good
metric to predict,
you know,
new criminality and it never really
works.
It was patterned after
program that they did in the south.
So it's kind of like they took the names
and birth dates off of bunch of files
and they pass them around and
miraculously every single one of them
was black.
Now numbers wise,
is that possible?
Like is it possible that all the people
that were the top 20 had the most amount
of violent convictions,
the most amount of this,
the most amount of that and that was
just,
they just happened to be black?
Is that possible?
It is not possible because I had other
clients who beat them.
Right.
You need the criteria.
I've worst people.
Everybody in that courthouse had
somebody that was worse than anybody on
that fucking list.
That's insane.
So you're saying like literally the,
you could replace the list with white
people that were violent,
dangerous criminals and it would be a
better choice.
Absolutely.
The dangerous.
It's so dangerous.
People were not even in the top 10.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If they wanted,
like if they wanted to know who the
biggest fucking maniacs and that in Dane
county where they could have just asked
the defense attorneys,
we wouldn't have told them.
Right.
But she knew the answers that isn't that
a tricky situation to be in.
Yeah.
I would imagine that.
Um,
it's incredibly stressful being someone
who's representing someone who you think
is like a real criminal,
a bad person,
and you have to try to get them off.
Yeah.
That it's,
it's weird.
But the thing is this system only works
if you just come at the other side and
the other side just comes at you because
you've got,
you know,
they've got the police behind them.
They've got the fact that they've got a
badge that impresses,
you know,
civilians during the jury trial,
they've got prosecutors who have access
to state crime labs.
They're going to come at you and if they
lose,
it's their fault.
So they have to win these ones.
So,
and the guilty guys give you an
opportunity to practice because you,
if you only took the cases of people who
you thought were innocent,
you would suck when it came time to do
their trial.
Like you got to practice,
you've got to sharpen your clause.
And the best way to do it is,
you know,
when with someone where you know that
they fucking did it and when it clean on
technical points because those technical
points like,
you know,
not getting evidence in or when a
prosecutor is asking questions during
wild deer,
they shouldn't be that type a little,
those little back flips and shit,
those will pay off when you actually
have a client that you don't think did
it.
So,
uh,
Ooh,
I understand.
I understand what you're saying and it
sort of your obligation.
And so in that sense,
you almost treat it like it's a game
that you're playing,
like some sort of a technical game.
You have to treat it as a technical game
or you will lose
because is it,
it's something,
I mean,
I'd know very,
very little about the law in terms of
defending people,
but is it something that you think is
like a almost like sort of a chess game?
Like you have a bunch of pieces and you
have to manipulate them correctly and
you have to be aware of the massive,
massive amounts of things that have been
written on each individual subject,
whether individual crime,
what precedents have been set,
how to establish whether or not they're,
your client was treated fairly.
And is that based on precedents to,
yeah.
Yeah,
there's precedent for everything.
Um,
you know,
346 million people in the country,
like they've had some court cases.
So yeah,
there's,
you have to know the general progress of
how a trial goes.
You have to know when someone can invoke
a right and when they can't invoke a
right time.
Limits are kind of important.
Um,
time limits.
Time limits.
Yeah.
Oh,
and it's like how,
like what statute of limitations?
Time limits?
Is that what you mean?
Statute of limitations to,
even if you're in court and you don't
object on time.
Yeah,
you're screwed.
Then they have to argue in a different
way to try and get it flipped over.
But there's always arguing.
Right.
Um,
but yeah,
it is a game and it is kind of mental.
Well,
here's an example.
Um,
I did this to a guy,
he's now,
um,
he's not a prosecutor there anymore,
but when you go into courtrooms in large
areas,
they take their inmates from the in
custody section.
Sometimes there'll be in a jail next to
her and they'll bring them from a tunnel
or a little holding cells in the
courthouse.
So they'll bring them in one side of the
courtroom and then they'll put the jury
box on the opposite side of the
courtroom so that the in custody
defendant doesn't walk past them on the
way in and out.
Because if they were to get sentenced
and the jury were sitting there on their
way out,
there may be some choice words.
So they separate the two of them.
Um,
and also because you know,
they're worried about them fleeing or
whatever,
but the net,
the actual effect of that is the
prosecutor's sits closer to the jury box
and they always have a case officer who
sits next to the prosecutor in their
dress uniform or they're,
you know,
they're working a form and they look at
the jury and they monitor the jury and
they keep their notes and they help them
and they mug and they listened to the
entire trial so they know what's going
on.
So it's a great asset to them,
but a substantial part of the advantage
that they get from having that chair,
having the officer being able to look at
the jury.
Because
think about you sitting in a room and
you're trying to figure out what the
fuck is going on.
Maybe it's a knife fight.
Maybe somebody supposedly shot at
somebody and a jury and you know,
the witness leans forward and says
something and you don't know if you
should believe him.
So you look to the judge,
judges blank and then you look to the
court reporter and the clerk of courts
blank blank because they don't want you
to be able to read them or they're
working on other shit or they're
concentrating on writing what everybody
is saying.
Then you get to the,
you know,
you get to the defense table and there's
the,
you know,
defendant looking guilty as shit as they
always do.
Um,
not really,
but,
and then you get to the prosecutor and
the cop and there the cops looking at
you and he just gives you an [inaudible]
and there you go.
You've got some validation for your
suspicion that the person was not
telling the truth just a little bit.
And that rolls forward from time to
time.
Like when you tell jokes on stage,
sometimes you hold for a second and you
fucking look at people and then they
start to laugh.
It's the same shit.
It's just their work in the crowd.
And they don't even know that they're
doing it.
But when they lean forward to answer a
question that the prosecutor acid they
want to answer,
or when they lean back because you asked
them a question and they're about to
burn you,
their work in the fucking crowd,
they're just working the crowd.
So what I would do is I would show up
early as shit and I would take their
table.
I would just put my shit at their table
because their name's not on the table.
Most juvenile bullshit ever.
I would take the table and I would put
all my stuff there and I would make them
ask the judge to move me because that
was not an argument that someone who
went to Harvard came to the courthouse
prepared to make cause my opponent that
they did go to Harvard and fuck Harvard
especially,
you know like this is the streets like
this is fuck around time.
So I did that just to an horse,
him mentally so that when the trial did
start,
he was uncomfortable.
I didn't care if I won or lost that
argument.
I wanted that chair.
I wanted that cheer cause I knew what we
could do.
Looking back at forth that,
those people and just taking them that
much further from the physical proximity
of the jury putting us clothes.
I wanted it for that reason,
but more so than that.
I just wanted to make him be a fucking
six year old to the judge.
Uh,
that's beautiful movement.
That's an excellent move.
And so it's,
you know,
like it's playing around and it's
definitely,
but it's also the whole system's kind of
juked anyway.
Right?
Well even your best to,
yeah.
I mean the thing is like if I can play
for that advantage and it's not
unethical or illegal because I can
explain why that chair is better and why
I want it,
then I'm,
I kind of have to play that angle
because I would hate for my client that
day to be like,
well,
so you had a chance to really mind fuck
them before you started and you didn't.
And now I'm convicted.
Right.
Well thanks.
They're not gonna,
you know.
Well,
how many guys who are working in your
position have such a clear mindset
though?
How many people have sort of punched out
after a while cause they've been doing
it a long time.
Or is that a public misconception that
you see in like movies where the,
you know,
the,
the criminal defendant that gets
assigned by the state doesn't really
give a fuck.
Does a half house job and the guy gets
sent up river.
Is that common or is it bullshit?
It's bullshit.
It's bullshit because we all do care.
Um,
we're competitive.
Even if we hate you,
we're going to try to win.
Especially if we hate you.
Like I've pulled like some of my best
moves all the time for people that I
loathed because it was the hardest move
to pull and it would be the biggest win.
And I,
you know,
like it doesn't matter how you feel
about the person.
Do you like winning?
I keep winning.
Like when you see somebody and they want
seven years and you go fuck you three,
you don't say fuck you,
but you just think you want seven years
for this shit.
Seven years of someone's life,
you maniac.
I don't care.
I don't even want this guy out,
but seven,
no.
So then you work on an argument,
so they after work you can tell
everybody that the prosecution asked for
seven and you got him to wow.
Because yeah,
winning is its own reward.
I've never heard a lawyer put it quite
like that,
like that.
Honestly,
you know,
we've talked about it before on the
podcast where I think that there's a
real problem with cops arresting
criminals and not that they shouldn't,
but there's a real problem in that it
becomes a game.
Like you're trying to,
when you're trying to catch people for
doing things and you're trying to lock
them up and when you're trying to win
because that is a win.
You know,
if you get someone,
you lock them up,
you arrest them,
you catch them,
they get convicted,
they go up river.
I sat him up river,
I went and that is an absolute,
it's,
there's a,
there's a certain amount of what,
what we've sort of developed all
throughout high school years and junior
high school and whatever.
Kids play sports and we developed this
winning mentality.
The game is to be one,
you know,
whether it's a game of pool or lawn
darts are fucking basketball.
People are always trying to win.
And when you have people that have
raised in some of the most intense
moments of their life,
especially if you're,
you've been involved in competitive
sports,
like if you've been on a championship
baseball team or something like that,
you go from that and your,
your next experiences in life or being a
police officer,
you're going to definitely take that
sports mindset and apply it to chasing
down criminals.
And it could be good and it can be bad.
But the problem is when people start
justifying certain things like planting
evidence and doing things along those
lines in order to get a conviction
because they want to win,
that's when shit gets really,
really scary because someone has an
incredible amount of power.
And if someone is doing something to
make you look more guilty,
just so that they can win.
That's scary.
Yeah.
Um,
when people were upset about the New
England patriots being accused of
cheating.
Yeah.
Deflate gate to was Jamie,
can you explain that?
Because I don't necessarily understand
it.
Uh,
they just,
during the nfl,
I think it was the championship game a
couple of years ago,
during the,
before the game,
a trainer supposedly had let some air
out of the ball,
which would make it easier to grip and
throw and catch.
Now,
that's what I don't understand it does
that been proven?
That had happened that it's easier to
catch a ball.
And there's other NFL quarterbacks I've
heard recently that admit to over
inflating a ball for the similar
reasons.
It's just preference on how to grip a
boss and my baseball players do stuff to
baseball,
but it's,
pitchers aren't allowed to scuff it,
but they,
they beat up a ball so that it's not
brand new and slippery at all.
This is why I got confused,
but hasn't had been proven or am I wrong
that it's like there's no like
measurable.
I think it was like the amount that it
actually was for there was like a 0.0018
amount of air selected.
That's an immeasurable amount of dif.
I really don't think it was.
Uh,
it was so,
it was bullshit.
Bullshit chair most part yet.
And it still isn't,
it's just that they want to win and if
he wants to win in this case,
yeah,
that's what it is like and then uh,
cause they couldn't get,
I'm very much on when they were
listening to everybody's place cause
they were,
they were reviewing everyone else's
plays in intercepting their
communications.
How are they doing that?
Radios and that's illegal.
It's not illegal depending on the state
that you're in,
but it's frowned upon.
It's,
that's unethical.
The teams are not supposed to be
eavesdropping on the play calls.
Right.
So they were taping them to videotaping
practices and catching hand signals.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And Dis ciphering hand signals like
fucking enemies.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's like some World War II Japanese
like code type Shit,
right?
Yeah.
That's why they hold up this big ass
science now with like five different
pictures.
Your decoy guys given fake hand signals.
There's all kinds of things going on in
that center.
Subterfuge.
Yeah.
Danger.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So it's like the cops are kind of like
the New England patriots,
like they're going to win anyway.
Why do you cheat?
You're going to win because the Patriots
were going to win almost all of those
games anyway.
But if they don't,
the planning of evidence and stuff like
that's,
it's more sensational.
It's more rare than you would think.
And the cops trying to get a particular
person is more rare than you think.
Like most cops are pretty good and don't
hold grudges like that.
And when you see a cop who's arrested
somebody like four times before they get
along,
like there's,
there's a little bit of trash talk in a
little bit of like,
hey,
how's it going?
Like they have relationships with people
that they have to arrest a lot to get,
are not always negative.
Like it's,
it's fucking hilarious.
It's like the sheep dog and the coyote,
those cartoons born Sam Morton and
monorail.
Yeah.
It's just like that.
And so yeah,
it's just,
they're not as bad as people make them
out to be in that angle.
Like there have been some terrible
scandals like rampart,
but most almost,
you know,
like that's not,
that's the shit that's not really
happening.
Like that's the TV shit.
What really happens is they're just not
allowed to lose any interaction.
Like they can't,
like when they finally decided that they
don't have to chase people in
California,
if they're going like one 20 less people
started dying because the cops actually
had the discretion to go,
we don't need to win all the time,
you know,
but all these other things like domestic
violence arrests or shoplifting or
Tasers,
like they can't leave,
they can net,
you can't back off a cop.
You can't be like,
no man,
I'm not going.
Because they have to get more cops and
they have to keep getting more cops with
bigger guns until they get you.
They not allowed to walk away and that,
and they're not allowed to walk away
from like personal interaction that
that's the problem is that we don't let
them be themselves.
We make them be kind of these,
you know,
like just always challenging people.
Right.
They don't want to do that.
But that's how they're taught that they
have to kind of act around people and
they drop it whenever they can.
Like a lot of them
through,
you know,
some guys never drop it cause they
really get off on that shit.
Sorry.
Put your hands on the hood of the car.
So spread your legs.
Yeah Sir.
But a lot of them would not like to talk
to people that way.
Right.
They just that they're taught,
they have to do that.
They're in a terror,
terrifying and dangerous situation a lot
of times where they literally have to
have complete total control of that
person and compliance.
If they don't have compliance,
it leaves open the door to,
to weird shit.
If a guy's not assuming the position,
they can become more threatening.
I kind of get it in,
in,
in violent crime situations,
but it's just gotta be insanely
difficult to figure out when to turn
that on and when to turn that off.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
some people obviously have problems with
that to fucking difficult job
emotionally to manage and
psychologically to manage.
You're in this position where you have a
gun all the time and a good percentage
of the people you talk to all day or
full of shit,
they're lying to you.
They're about to commit a crime mean
imagine running into people and almost
everyone you see is involved in
something they shouldn't be involved in.
And you took the job because you like
people,
you know,
like you took the job because you wanted
to protect people and have people
respect you and all you get is fucking
disrespect and picking up shoplifters
and heaven turds thrown at you by some.
And then teenagers make fun of you
remember what it was like after nine 11,
how that big shift came about and people
like really appreciative of uh,
they started calling them a first
responders.
It was like the first time they had to
call them first responders.
It was like a common expression in the
news cause it used to be,
you know,
uh,
emergency people,
nine 11,
it would be cops or firemen.
But when they started calling him first
responders and people were like super
happy to see cops and super happy to see
firefighters,
especially for quite a while.
They've got a lot of respect.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it kind of wore off.
I mean,
firefighters I think still get there was
they get most of what they used to get.
They don't get the full blast that they
used to get,
but now cops,
every time one of them fucks up showing
up on video and it's reflecting poorly
on everybody.
But we really do have to take any
consideration to two factors when you're
looking at these videos.
One is the sheer amount of crime you're
talking about that takes place on a
daily basis.
So what you're saying is if you have,
I mean,
think of the many,
many,
many cities in this country and the
many cops having interactions with the
many,
many people who have committed crimes.
It's pretty rare.
You see a video of a cop doing something
really fucked up in consideration to
that when you're talking about these
millions of interactions and to have one
every couple months.
People like,
God dammit,
what one of these fucking people going
to stop doing that?
Well,
a,
it is good,
very good that we have a now to catch
those people and weed those people out
so they don't exist anymore.
That's a beautiful thing.
But B,
we,
it's certainly like had an impact
knowing that they're going to be filmed
w knowing that it's likely to be filmed,
it's gonna eliminate some of the,
uh,
some of the corruption,
some of the evil shit that we've caught
cops doing.
It was definitely gonna have pressure on
them and social pressure that's going to
cause people to change their opinions
and change the way they conduct business
or they conduct the business of law
enforcement.
But at the end of the day,
the numbers are shockingly small.
If you really stop and think about it,
how much,
I mean,
I'm not trying to be like a cop
pathologist,
but I'm just saying we really should
take into consideration whenever we do
any of these conversations about it,
how many fucking cops there are,
how many crimes they're handling on a
daily basis,
and how insanely brutal that must be on
your psychological system,
your emotional system.
I've,
I've maintained a few times and I don't
think it's a job that,
I think it's a job that very few people
are qualified for.
I think you have a,
you have to have a very strong mind to
be able to handle that in a very fair
way.
Yeah.
It's gotta be intensely.
Could you imagine just getting shot at
you like,
well,
fucking high speed chases catching
people in the middle of the crimes.
Domestic violence.
Yeah.
Well that's,
I mean it's not all excitement.
A lot of it is a lot of it.
It's sad.
It's sad for them because they'll show
up four or five times to the same house.
Oh yeah.
You know,
that's,
and they don't,
they don't like that.
A lot of times they'll get all the
cases,
they'll get a case nice and ready and
then the lady doesn't show up,
the cases dismissed and then four months
later there's another call and she's
back at the house.
That shit,
it's got a great on them I'm sure.
But like the,
I mean the police brutality videos bring
to light kind of a way that some
officers have been getting away with
treating people like Rodney King was,
uh,
was one of the first prime examples of
like cops get away with doing this to
people and yeah.
And it don't you think in the Rodney
King situation though,
it was pretty extreme because you're
dealing with a PCP it up,
dude that went on a high speed chase and
there was a lot more to that video then
what we saw on television.
Like I'm not excusing them for beating
the shit out of him like that.
I mean,
they should have definitely handcuffed
him and they should have figured out a
way with all those guys to restrain him.
They should have the physical manpower
to restrain that guy without beating on
him like that.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
my personal belief is if you lead the
police on a high speed chase,
they should beat your ass when you get
out of the car.
Uh,
that's what I've,
I mean that's what they generally do
because they're jacked up from having to
drive at that speed.
And I don't really say,
I'm not saying like it's morally right.
I'm saying like if you're currently in a
high speed chase with the police,
pull over slowly
and expect,
you know,
a few kisses on the lips.
This is my problem with that.
I don't have a problem with it in terms
of like dishing out justice,
but that's first of all kind of smacks
of vigilantism.
Right.
And second of all,
because you're not really supposed to do
that right now.
They're not supposed to,
but it's that I don't think they can
control.
It's not vigilantism it's a cop.
What,
what'd you call it?
Just,
uh,
it's just inappropriate violence.
Well,
it's,
I mean,
they're trying to take physical control
immediately.
Have somebody who just like threatened
the lives,
like threatened the lines of like,
I don't know,
50 or 60 people,
like they're going to do it fast.
But here's my only concern is that it
would encourage people to get away with
more,
more on the line because you know,
if they get pulled over,
they're gonna get the fuck beat out of
them.
And it could cause loss of other
people's lives if they were involved in
a car accident by someone.
It's frantic to not get the shit beat
out of him by cops.
Yeah.
I just don't think you're supposed to
green light when someone can beat the
fuck out of.
No,
no,
no.
Shooting him,
killing him.
It just sounds so hypocritical and
stupid,
but that almost makes more sense.
I'm not,
I'm not saying like I greenlight,
I'm saying like we are dealing with
people.
Yeah.
It's pro.
It's going to have going to happen.
What's going to happen?
We need to figure out how to handle
that.
We don't want it to happen,
but it's,
that's,
I mean we're not using robots.
We're using paypal.
Exactly.
And I think that's what's most important
that we're talking about here.
And um,
when,
when we can take people and categorize
them and say,
well this guy has x amount of melanin in
his skin and his family's from this part
of the world,
so we'll apply rule A.
Yeah.
Versus if this guy is Norwegian,
white looking motherfucker like
yourself.
You apply rule be when you look at some
Sweden in you when you got there from
Norwegian,
look at that.
How about that?
I'm not,
I'm not even good at that.
Yeah,
you're really good at racism.
You're a very good white guy.
Well,
it's okay if you do it with white
people.
Racism.
Is that racism?
No,
that's not racism.
Who would that be?
It used to be racism.
It's only if it's black person.
I can't call it,
like if I call you,
if I say that you look Norwegian and I
nail it,
that is definitely not racism.
But if I see a black person for Haiti
and I'm like the Congo,
well that would be right.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can't get away with that.
Especially if it's like a really bad
place.
I pick cotton.
Well,
I think also it was,
the east sounded really excited when he
did it.
Like Congo.
Yeah,
well that was for the punchline.
Okay.
I didn't know.
Trying to be the tool to try and make
some jokes.
Um,
yeah man.
I think,
um,
it's,
uh,
it's just real disturbing.
It was very disturbing when you were
telling me this because it just doesn't
make a whole lot of sense that some
place that people would think of as such
a liberal open minded place like
Madison,
Wisconsin would be so,
so fucking backwards like that and that
no one's bringing this up.
Uh,
people have tried to bring it up.
Um,
they first started
bringing it up in 2012.
Since then,
it's gotten worse.
Um,
a couple of places have come out with
studies on it.
Um,
basically in Wisconsin,
uh,
adult black men are 12 times more likely
to be sent to prison than white guys.
Uh,
black kids are 16 times more likely to
be put into foster care than white kids.
Uh,
and of course if you're in foster care
then you're more likely to be
prescribed,
you know,
pills and all that fun stuff.
And even for that,
like in La County,
uh,
black foster kids are eight times more
likely to be put on behavior altering
medication,
then white kids also in foster care.
So it's,
they noticed that the numbers were
really getting bad then and then they
tried some shit to fix it and it just
gotten worse.
I guess
the funniest one was,
I think it was in 2014 then when there
was another study that says,
Ooh,
it's still getting worse.
Uh,
they proposed a $250,000 a gardening
initiative where they would teach
children to garden.
You're locking up 50% of all African
American men from 18 to 25 they're in
jail or on probation.
And your idea is to spend a quarter of a
million dollars on gardening.
No,
fucking wonder.
Shit's fucked up.
So what was the argument about the
gardening?
It was going to give them a sense of
purpose because they would see these
flowers and fuck if I know,
but that's,
yeah,
like it's one of the like it's hippy
dippy bullshit is what it is.
It's fucking like,
I don't like,
like holy fucking yellow brick road.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Like are we all grown ups in this room?
I leave really.
We've noticed some studies that came out
of Norway where they took prisoners and
they showed them how to make tomato
sandwiches and they could grow their own
tomatoes.
They got so much more comfortable.
But being a person like let's,
let's keep stealing fathers from their
children and then also,
but you know how we took your dad.
This is the magic of Patagonia.
You know,
like you know,
story,
we fucking shattered your family but
aren't lilacs beautiful and you have to
ride the bus to come see your lilacs.
It's just horse shit.
It's just,
if that's what they think will make a
difference,
then we're fucked.
Yeah.
I mean that's probably a good idea for
like maybe a community center that wants
to help kids out and give them some
sense of purpose,
but a sort of subscribe that to
criminals are the people that you've
convicted of crimes or people that
you've put
in jail.
Like
just anybody and you can't make people
garden.
It's like we actually had a war about
that.
There was a war about 150 years ago
about making people garden based on the
color of their skin.
It was the civil war.
I found an article about it.
What I'm saying?
Yeah.
The anecdotes from this are kind of fun
if you want to read it.
I've been locked up my whole life.
So doing programs like this are like
planting a seed.
He said you have to nurture a plant
almost like a kid.
It's kind of weird to think about it
that way,
but I think it's going to show me how to
become an adult.
Wow.
And he said that after he brained the
social worker and raped her dead body,
can I,
can I do it and pr style?
Yes.
And after everyone had a chance to talk,
it was time for some hands on gardening.
One table was just covered with dried
lupin in Larkspur plants that the
inmates stripped of seeds.
After the gardening work was done,
the inmates gathered again in a circle
to talk about how to connect what
they've learned from life after they
released.
John is currently serving time for his
six drunk driving convictions.
A little too sexy.
It's
pretty good.
But you're a little too sultry.
You Burn,
you burn sign.
You burn it a little slower but you do
burn.
He got to be a little more dry.
To me it's the self satisfaction.
No,
there's,
there's like almost like a hipstery
quality that you have to acquire over
your,
your sound as well.
Okay,
I'll work on that.
It's pretty good though.
What is going on with that voice that
they do that one thing.
We're men.
You that.
Okay.
Here's a perfect example.
That dude who was a in Canada who got in
trouble with all the ladies because they
said that he liked to throttle them.
I'm that dude.
Uh,
John Ghomeshi.
Do you know who he is?
Okay.
He was the guy that was on trial in
Canada because a,
a bunch of girls that you hooked up with
city beat the shit out of him.
Blow the fucking like the Canadian like
male feminists.
That guy.
Oh,
he was always there.
He was a male feminist who talks like
this and has a very,
very subdued way of speaking.
So tell us about your band and where,
where did you guys start out?
Like in this,
you know,
that weird,
not a real person sort of a thing going
on.
He was the king of that shit.
That,
what is that?
What?
What,
what does that gender neutral sort of
strange when you talk like this?
Yeah.
No.
What is that?
Why are they doing that?
They're trying to relax.
You almost like hypnotize you into not
just going with it.
There's no emotion to it.
It's like a soft rock dj,
but,
but yeah,
a little creepier.
It's like a,
you know what though?
Honestly,
I'd have to say I prefer it when I'm
listening to like very intelligent
things.
Yeah.
Like if I'm listening to like,
yeah,
cause you don't want to hear somebody be
like,
yeah,
the fuck at Tampa pusha ablation has how
the modern nuclear weapon operates.
Yeah,
exactly.
Or even when someone's discussing like
when they're talking about like a very
intense subject that's a hotly into
debate.
I almost prefer it like this
nonjudgmental weird sort of not really a
person way of communicating the pan
determined we going to get classical
music almost.
Yeah.
Like that eight a classical music.
You can retain the knowledge better so
to speak that way.
Well I'm fascinating as as a comic I'm
fascinated by all those different.
Um,
there's like pre determined patterns
that people can plug into.
Like you can become a top 40 dj and
everybody knows how to do it.
Top 40 DJ style.
All right.
There's just a way of talking where it
just say,
oh well this guy is going to play me
some top 40 songs.
I know his voice.
He's on the ball,
you know,
he's doing it.
Perfect.
Strip club Djs and other one.
It's like a similar one politician
voice.
This is a bunch of different voices that
people are allowed to plug into.
Yeah.
I guess cop voice to you could,
you could add cop voice to that to comp
voice.
Yeah.
Hillary Clinton is so bad at public
speaking.
She's terrible at it,
right?
Like how do you do it that long and suck
that bad?
Oh my God.
Well,
you know what,
man,
I think she's tired for one.
I bet if he caught her when she was 40
she was probably a firecracker.
Yeah.
You know,
she's a lady that's dealing with a
failing older body and it's a real
problem for people because they don't
really get wise enough for us to
consider them running the nation until
they're older.
You know?
Like if Katy Perry wanted to be
president tomorrow and be like pitching,
I old enough,
she's not.
She's not 35 all right.
But for when she started,
okay,
Jennifer Aniston,
she's,
she's 35 she's like 42 or something like
that.
She's not a good judge of character.
She's hot as fuck.
She's really hot.
But she's had,
she never did anything to her chin.
So strong chin.
Still work.
Yes.
Chain is,
don't sell yourself short,
but like if she wanted to become
president would be like,
get the fuck out of here.
You're too vibrant.
You're too young,
you have too much going on.
It's a real catch 22 for a woman.
Yeah.
Cause like the only way you would accept
a woman in office as a woman,
like an old withered politician like
Hillary who's been in the trenches.
I
yeah.
Yeah.
I think you kind of have to be a little
close to death for people to vote for
you,
for president.
It's true.
You've got to look a little bit like
shit.
Well we tried it with Obama with a,
a really vibrant guy and he came out
looking like death came out looking 20
years old.
We were bastard.
Yeah.
I think we bothered him way more than he
thought we would bother.
Oh,
100% at mean just the job itself.
I don't think any,
I think it's the same thing we were
talking about.
Like it's really difficult to be a cop
magnet time that time.
What a million magnify that.
Probably more than a million.
And you've got with the president is,
yeah,
I mean the,
the,
the sheer volume of information that
that guy must have to process on a daily
basis about international affairs.
She,
Putin in Syria and Saudi Arabia is doing
what and what's going on in Turkey in
the fucking terror attack and France and
oh yeah.
Jesus Christ
just has to decide bullshit over and
over and over again because your body
keeps fucking shit up for him and now
he's got to deal with it.
That just internationally he's supposed
to take care of national stuff too.
So stop and think about that.
He,
it's like he's got a hundred really
fucking strong opinionated neighbors who
like to fight with each other and you've
got to somehow under the negotiate peace
settlements and,
and,
and even send some of your thugs to
watch over certain areas to protect them
from shit getting crazy.
And he's constantly supposed to be
communicating with all these generals
and processing all that stuff.
Yep.
God.
And then on top of it,
he's supposed to be fixing the economy
and then on top of it he's supposed to
be straightening out the problem with
people having student loans that are
vastly more than their actual education.
Yeah.
Fuck that job.
He,
he's a dumb ass for trying to get that
job.
That's too much work for too little
money.
But he's a lawyer.
Yeah.
And he wanted to win.
Yup.
Competitive.
That's probably it,
right?
Yeah.
You get on that track.
I get,
you know,
maybe he was like,
fuck,
I'm a senator from Illinois,
so I guess my choices or get the fuck
out here and go to prison like every
other elected official from Illinois.
Yeah.
What was the,
was it Detroit?
Which,
what city was it where,
um,
what was like the big arrest recently?
Oh yeah.
Somebody in Detroit,
the Mayor of Detroit,
I believe it was.
The mayor was like,
I don't want to say that.
I should be real clear.
I don't know if it was really the mayor,
so don't sue me.
Yeah.
But someone got some pilot for something
almost hilarious.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was like whenever a mayor gets popped
for something sexual,
it's fucking riot.
Well,
the my favorite mayor stuff of all time
was Marion Barry when he got caught
smoking crack,
went to jail.
Got Out of jail and want again.
Yeah.
Oh,
that was beautiful one again.
Former Mayor of Detroit a couple of
years ago got sentenced to prison.
What was it for?
Prison corruption.
Yeah.
That's okay.
That's it.
Yeah.
He was the former mayor when he got
arrested.
Yeah.
That's the dude x Detroit mayor.
It's two 28 years in prison for
corruption.
Woos name is,
is that Quami?
Quami Quami Quami 28 years for
corruption falling series of scandals
that showed that he had unchecked power
while in office.
Bam.
Unchecked
motherfucker like empire.
I haven't seen empire,
but those what it looks like.
Unchecked power.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Damn.
Why else would it be mayor once,
once get his freak on.
I know mayor.
This is the thing is imagine if you went
on
a path to being president 20 years ago,
which Obama most likely dead,
right?
Yeah.
So think about it.
He,
what is he now?
He's like 50 so back then he was 30 and
if you think about when he was 30 and
he's thinking to himself,
you know,
I'm going to be the president in United
States,
I'm on this path,
and I'm seeing all the pussy that John
F.
Kennedy got and I'm seeing all the power
that all these other presidents had.
And I'm seeing,
I'm seeing it,
seeing all the respect that they got
when they got out of office and then as
obviously,
definitely didn't think that he would
get all the pussy that jfk,
he's,
I'm sure he's a faithful man.
It's just in the,
in the vein of humor.
But it's nice to be offered.
Yeah.
It's nice to know that you've got,
you could possibly have the kind of
power to shut the lights out on people,
make them disappear.
So he does that.
He does.
He could.
Right.
And then in those 20 years,
you see the world change so drastically.
Well,
you can't,
he see Clinton get popped with Monica
Lewinsky.
Yeah.
That was step one.
Like,
Oh shit,
I still want to do this.
Yeah,
I believe this.
And then,
but Bush managers to go through and then
social media comes around and in the
midst of the social media world,
that's when Obama steps in.
So the amount of scrutiny and insults
and the amount of data that's directed
his way as opposed to every other
president before him.
It's like unprecedented.
Yeah.
There's never been a guy that's been
subject to so many different signals of
negativity coming as wet.
Cause before that people were sort of
voiceless.
They couldn't really do anything.
But in Obama's time blogs became a way
more prominent online news sources and
many people's world replaced the,
the regular newsprint.
Yeah.
So it's not just what do they talk?
What are they saying to me?
All about me in the New York Times,
it's
thousands of different blogs and it's
amazing,
man.
Amazing change of events that have
rendered the position incredibly
unattractive.
So then eight years later,
this is what you get.
You get crazy old Bernie sanders with
his fucking wacky hairdo.
Yeah.
Who hates money?
You get crazy old Hillary Clinton who's
shrieking and she's built like a fucking
converse all star box.
The whole thing is she's,
I mean,
she looks like her body's failing.
Like it makes me uncomfortable and I see
her.
I think she's probably fine.
I think she's probably in good health.
I just think they don't know,
man.
I just think she's not,
I know how bad she wants it,
but she doesn't have charisma and,
but even if she got it,
look,
look at the amount of fucking stress
that's involved in that job.
How can that possibly be healthy for
someone who's really older,
she'll handle it.
Do you think fun?
Yeah.
If she were to get the job,
she would handle that better than Obama
probably had because she's been in the
trenches her whole life,
right?
Yeah.
She's fucking like,
you got no question that she knows how
to the game.
It's a game to her and that she's trying
to win.
She's trying to do some nice shit for
people.
You know,
she's trying to help people out,
but completely cynical,
you know,
100% I mean,
she was the secretary of state.
She's had people killed,
you know,
she's ordered drone strikes.
Oh a hundred percent.
So we'll do you,
she's fine.
You saw her reaction to Gadhafi you saw
the news piece,
what these people were talking to her
and she sits down.
She goes,
uh,
we came,
we saw he died.
Huh?
Yeah.
Seen that right?
No,
no,
no.
You must watch it cause there a thug
life version of it too.
That's the one that put up,
pull up the fuck life version of it.
But it just shows you again,
what was she,
she was a lawyer.
She was a lawyer and these lawyers who
eventually become politicians,
they like to win.
I just that what my physical like people
are like,
why,
why do you worry about her physically?
Maybe I didn't explain or maybe you
haven't heard.
Um,
it is alleged and I think it's,
it's sort of been reported on that she
had blacked out and falling and hitting
her head recently in the last few years.
She's 70 [inaudible] it's gonna happen.
But um,
that she had had a fairly traumatic
brain injury from that.
That was something that,
just pull that up,
Jamie.
See if he could find that story because
that might be republican bullshit.
I might be like,
uh,
well I'll lift relating republican
propaganda also.
Uh,
Ronald Reagan had some brain damage and
he was amazing.
You know,
like maybe,
maybe we don't get a president with a
hundred percent thinker.
It doesn't matter.
I mean it definitely matters.
But at this point in time,
I wonder what the Ronald Reagan thing
was.
Interesting.
Cause he deteriorated as he was in
office.
He started off very fresh.
If you go back and listen to some of his
early speeches like wrong,
Reagan gave me hell of a speech.
Like tear down that wall.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
He,
he had that one super bizarre speech.
Do you remember this one where um,
he was standing in front of the United
Nations,
I believe,
and he gave a speech about how quickly
we would all put our differences aside
if we were attacked by aliens from
another planet.
He's 100% right.
He was 100%.
He is 100% right.
But I mean it was one of the strangest
fucking speeches ever.
And the like.
It is one that the Ufo lovers have clung
to like a life raft.
He knew it was going to tell us.
He knew me.
Yeah.
He's like,
yeah,
I remember that Cold War that we just
all of a sudden stopped in 1989
yeah.
Work on lasers.
If you have you seen that one,
that speech.
It's,
it's really interesting.
I'll look that up.
Did you find the Hillary won the thug
life one?
I found a thug life one,
but I'm not sure that it's about
Gadhafi.
Oh,
okay.
I came,
we saw he died.
If that's the speech,
she's like sitting,
getting interviewed.
Thing I find about brain cancer is like
national and corner got brain cancer.
No,
no,
no.
She fell and hit her.
Yeah,
I've found anything about that.
A concussion she has.
She might be suffering from post
concussion syndrome.
Is this from the inquirer?
This is not from that.
From breitbart.
Okay.
Might as well be earlier this year.
I know.
I didn't find anything for much other
and regarding that,
so there's,
so I did repeat Republican propaganda.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Lisa called myself out all that.
That's how they get you find out what
that is in any way.
Substantiated.
I think she did have a concussion,
but I don't know like the or she's
suffering from it.
Okay,
well load.
That's when you're that old and you had
a concussion and you,
you're going to have some fucking
issues.
Yeah.
Oh,
what those issues are and whether or not
they're treatable.
That's,
that's uh,
something only she would know.
Yeah.
George Bush fucking puked his guts out
all over the prime minister of Japan.
We also fell and blacked out and hit his
head because he choked on a pretzel no
earlier.
George Bush.
Oh yeah.
Old School.
Herbert Walker.
Yep.
Yeah.
Remember when,
uh,
there was like,
that was the big conspiracy because Bush
had like bruises and a black eye and
shit and somebody,
somebody beat the fuck out of the
president,
but that he said he choked w with a
pretzel in his mouth and fell and hit
his face.
Like,
if I was the Illuminati and I was going
to beat up the president at,
that's what I would make them say.
Oh,
I want you to tell them that he choked
on a pretzel.
Yeah.
Ooh,
Ooh.
What happened?
He blacked out.
Stupid.
You fell and you hate your fucking head.
Okay.
And then you've got this black guy.
What?
Black Guy?
Hello?
Oh
yeah.
Do you think the Illuminati beat up
George Bush?
Tommy?
Uh,
now I think probably Dick Cheney had him
in the face.
Changes.
Beat the fuck out of him.
Yeah.
He's like,
fuck them too.
Yeah.
I mean,
but that was probably tender.
Like they got a history together.
I just have a bit about Dick Cheney
because Dick Cheney shot his friend in
the face and he made his friend
apologize.
Yeah,
no shit.
Dick Cheney's hard fucking car.
I mean,
come on man.
That guy was on TV apologizing for Dick
Cheney after Dick shot him in the face.
Yeah.
And he was like 70,
he shot him in the face at 70 with a
shotgun.
Yeah.
I put,
I put Hillary Clinton in Dick Cheney
kind of in the same boat as like the,
and you know,
like the Henry Kiss and you're like,
oh yeah,
they'll just now just do whatever.
You know,
like if they decide someone needs to go,
they'll just,
you know,
that's just that dictate who's a scary
guy and his,
he's also still involved.
Like he still,
he absolutely believes in voicing his
opinion and what shouldn't,
shouldn't be done internationally.
Like even now today.
And He's,
he scares me.
Yeah.
Well he has to be,
uh,
like he has to stay kind of involved
because you know that he committed war
crimes.
Everybody that
you know,
um,
I mean shit,
he fucking engineered war profiteering
against our own,
you know,
like,
so you think they'll start cheese,
he stays active so that he avoids
prosecution by constantly staying in the
mix.
Yeah,
and George Bush did the opposite,
so they both ran in separate directions.
Dick Cheney shows up and says,
wow,
we had to torture him cause we needed
intelligence.
Good.
That's good impression.
All right.
Try and then George Bush stays the fuck
out of it because if you notice,
those guys don't travel internationally
so much.
Yeah,
that's probably a bad move.
They don't travel internationally
because the jurisdiction for human
rights violations is worldwide.
It makes them technically hosty humanoid
Generis,
meaning enemies of mankind at large.
So just like Spain did with Pinochet,
any court can try them.
They just need to be able to say that
the courts in their home jurisdiction or
where it happened are not able to do it
and then they can do it.
So whoa,
they stay here.
They go to,
so do they have treaties with any
countries?
Like is there any country that they know
for sure won't prosecute them if they
travel internationally?
It,
yeah,
there's country.
There's jurisdictions where they know
won't prosecute them,
but they can go to the UK.
Well,
but the thing is the ability to
prosecute someone for war crimes under
the Hague.
And you know,
because these trend,
these human rights violation rules,
trump,
all the treaties,
they trump fucking everything except for
a couple small technical points.
So a county prosecutor in Nebraska could
file the charges against Dick Cheney.
Whoa.
And although that might violate United
States law and they might say you have
to do it here or here or here,
no technique.
I mean basically like so any
enterprising prosecutor in Spain,
if they could lay their hands on them,
they can do them.
Any body,
any process you.
So depending on the way that the country
organizes its prosecution system,
the lowest level person competent to
make the decision could potentially try
to jack a mom.
You know?
So like I know I'm saying like his level
of travel has to be so well coordinated
because fucking county sheriff could
take him in for this shit.
Wow.
The wrong county sheriff could pick him
up on this.
Has anybody ever tried to do that?
No.
And that's,
you know
why they don't travel?
Because they fact that nobody's ever
even tried to do that.
And the evidence is overwhelming and
clear that Dick Cheney,
you know,
for instance,
remember the Guy who authored the report
saying that torture was okay?
Yeah.
That itself is a violation of
international law for which you can be
prosecuted.
Yeah.
So,
and that's just,
that's the tip of the iceberg.
So that guy can't,
because when if he,
I mean they can travel a little bit,
but there's countries they can't go to
because they'll snap him up and
prosecute him because yeah.
These just,
I forget exactly what I'm talking like
it's hard to explain.
Anyone can prosecute him for any of this
shit.
Everybody has the proof and when he goes
to other countries,
they will use the fact that we have not
prosecuted him here as proof that we're
not going to,
which will allow them to go forward.
So all it would take would be like say
if he decides to make a trip to,
you know,
whatever.
Some European country yeah.
All would take is one ambitious person.
Yup.
That's what happened to Pinochet
and that was a,
I think a decade long fight.
That's why a so fascinating.
Yeah.
That's why Paul Pot never left Cambodia.
It's,
it's so also so fascinating that we have
these weird rules that the presidents
have.
Yeah.
Like we're a presence.
Can get away with certain things,
like they can admonish people or they
could,
uh,
rather,
um,
uh,
release people from jail.
Yeah.
They can suspend their senses
for federal offenses and governors can
do it for state offenses.
It's just one of those,
you got to have a release valve on some
shit and they use it like Bill Clinton
did it for a lot of political feminist
pardons.
The get as many as you want.
Wides.
Yeah.
Ben,
you can get someone out like for a
violent crime.
Um,
there is a,
depending on the jurisdiction,
for instance,
in Wisconsin,
there is no functional limit on the
power of the governor to let you out.
Yeah.
Or pardon you,
cause there's no limit.
He's the governor and other governors
before of him if instituted a sort of
boards that we'll review requests for
clemencies and pardons and shit like
that.
And they have ad hoc rules where they're
like,
well,
it's gotta be at least five years ago.
You've got to show us this and this and
this.
But in reality,
he could do whatever the fuck he wants.
That's insane.
Because he's the executive.
Uh,
county sheriffs also have the ability to
release people from jail.
Okay.
Because they run the jail.
A sentence only says that you should be
confined for this for x amount of time
and the governors in charge of the
Department of corrections so he can let
you out early if he feels like it.
And County sheriff is in charge of the
jail and if county sheriff needs the
room,
he can kick out.
That's what he did with Paris Hilton.
He said,
I need the bed for somebody else get up
and they can do that.
There are some minor checks on it and
prosecutors get really mad.
But no,
they,
they have almost unlimited,
almost free reign in the area of
pardons.
That's like some King Shit.
It is King Shit.
It is.
That is what kings can do.
It is the power of life and death.
The strange thing to give someone
that's,
it's,
it's so weird that that still exists.
It has to exist because you cannot trust
the courts to do fairness.
Really?
Yeah.
But you can trust the governor.
Courts are good for technical points.
Right.
But every now and again there's a guy
and he's in and the courts won't listen.
So the governor has got to be able to
let them out.
Like,
Oh man,
it seems like it opens a door for a lot
of fuckery.
It no,
because everybody's looking like you
can't pardon someone without anybody,
without everybody knowing.
Right.
But on a offense case,
you know when you're sitting on the
fence on it,
well they're,
yeah.
They're not going to influence someone
one way or another.
No.
I mean,
Nixon got,
pardon teddy really?
Who pardoned Nixon,
I don't know.
But Clinton pardoned his own brother,
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
You can just do that.
This drug offending brother and his
final executive actions,
and Susan Mcdougal,
his Whitewater business partner and a
low and a member of the Symbionese
Liberation Army.
Jesus Christ.
I also want to add that I was just
looking up that George Bush Cheney
thing.
Supposedly it's false that they don't
actually have outstanding warrants right
now.
No,
they don't have warrants or any,
they're not wanting necessarily know.
They're not wanted anyone can file the
charges.
So there's no,
yeah,
there's no,
no,
no one has to file charges,
but basically tens of thousands of
different prosecutors across the globe
could,
they can do it,
but they're not going to do it unless
they can get their hands on him.
This look at all the other,
the other list or rather the other
people on the list to Clinton pardoned.
He pardon that.
Michael Milkin junk bond king.
Oh.
Milkens got an office in Santa Monica.
Now that guy was,
that guy was terrible person.
He fuck people over bad,
right?
I mean,
did a lot of people get fucked over by
that guy?
Uh,
tons of people got fucked over by that
guy.
Um,
the Whitewater business partner too.
That's a,
that's crazy.
But now Michael Milkin has a nice little
foundation where he teaches kids,
uh,
music.
Look at this.
She,
uh,
Clinton friend from Arkansas spent 18
months in prison after refusing to give
evidence that might implicate the
president and first lady in a bank fraud
while he was the state's governor.
That's okay.
How much do you think she,
he,
she got paid
after he pardoned her?
How much she,
a paid shout.
Yay.
Yeah.
I mean they roll deep.
I'm sure she's doing fine.
Yeah.
How does that work though?
How do you,
uh,
how do you pay someone off like that and
foundation?
Oh yeah.
You give them a junction.
What a great idea.
Clinton Foundation,
the Clinton Foundation,
like one of those charities are like
you,
you go and look at exactly how much goes
to the actual actual cause.
Is it one of those things that pays
themselves and can take trips and
whatnot?
Really?
Isn't that adorable?
Did you see she got her FBI meeting this
weekend,
who did the three and a half hour
meeting with the FBI?
Hillary did.
I was seeing some other reports that
Bill Clinton had like a special in air
meeting with the,
one of the people that we're going to
talk to her before it and lay it.
Yeah.
Someone from Arizona or something like
that.
Is that where it was kind,
Kinda like he said he made a impromptu
trip to visitor who in prompt,
who's on jet?
Anybody?
Anybody out there?
Anybody impromptu and I mean like how
ball is he?
Yeah.
Well,
it was just doing the air.
I decided to go by and say hello and all
for a piece of Pie.
Yeah.
I was just coming over to be neighborly
and my fucking private jet.
He's super concerned about the
environment,
but yet flying around on private jets.
Well no,
that was his little brother Al Gore.
This whole thing is so rigged,
man.
It's,
it's such a strange,
strange world we're living in.
We're,
we're going to have,
what is this 20 years of supposedly
democracy and there's only two different
last names,
three different last names,
so thanks.
Obama.
Obama snuck in there.
They almost turned it around again with
this.
They wanted it to be Bush Clinton,
but Bush is not very good at it.
The sound chip guys just not very good
at it.
I feel like you threw in the towel like
he gave.
Like I feel like you're just like,
fuck you guys.
I don't want this job.
And he stumbled his way through some
shit.
Yeah.
Well I,
I bet you it was.
I bet ya he was a little hurt that he
didn't get picked for 2000 and then
there was a day where he was like,
whew,
thank God I'm not that guy.
You know,
I'm waiting for someone to get up there
and just go,
this job can't be done.
Don't elect me cause this job can't be
done.
No one can do this job.
I'm voting for you because if you vote
or I'm asking you to vote for me,
for me,
I'm going to get rid of this job.
Yeah.
The first thing I'm gonna do is
president is get rid of the president.
Yeah,
we may,
maybe we maybe need to,
presidents is a lot of things.
You need a council of elders,
so I can't preside over this shit.
Pardon Jimmy Hoffa.
But he was dead and then Jimmy or Nixon
was pardoned by Ford and that's what led
to him not getting reelected.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
So yeah,
that's what led to Ford not being
reelected.
Yay.
Have contributed to his defeat.
I'm,
it's not the only thing.
Oh,
so not a crook.
Also,
I think Ford's obsession with combating
inflation.
Did a man.
Did you ever see the uh,
thing that hunters Thompson did with
Bill Murray and it was um,
they were mock trying to bring Dick back
and see how many people would go for it.
They were just trying to show how easy
it is to manipulate people and how dumb
they are politically and he was trying
to bring back,
see if he could find that man.
It was like bring Nixon back,
you know,
bring Nixon back.
Then he had like Nixon masks stuff and
they were trying
to,
he got a bad deal.
He got a bum deal.
Yeah.
And they were talking to people on the
street and trying to convince them.
But it was bill Murray and hunter s
Thompson.
It was from
something Gonzo and Hollywood or
something like that.
It was like a documentary that they did.
This should probably be a clip of it
somewhere.
My family hated Richard Nixon growing up
because when Richard Nixon came to
Wisconsin rapids,
my grandfather arranged for a cadillac
for him as he got off the plane and to
address the people he stood on the
Cadillac,
scratch the hood with his shoes and
refuse to pay for it.
Whoa.
That was so not anything about the
spying.
That was not my family's problem with
Richard Nixon.
It was that he scratched the hood of a
Cadillac.
Well that was a piece of shit move.
Yeah.
And that shows man's character.
Like here's a,
here's an example.
My friend Brian Cowen.
Do you know Brian cal?
Yeah.
Met Him.
Hilarious.
Standup comedian.
Awesome human being.
He,
um,
his mom told him once that she caught a
guy cheating at golf and she told her
husband,
don't ever trust that guy.
Don't do business with them.
Cause he cheats at golf.
He'll cheat it.
Everything else too.
Yeah.
Just a casual game of golf amongst
friends and she caught him cheating.
Yeah.
Like man,
you know,
and when that bad,
yeah.
The golf that transfers over.
Yeah.
It really does.
So in that sense,
what are you looking up again?
Still haven't found it.
I got a picture of Bill Murray with
Thompson and the Nixon thing,
but nothing,
oh,
I
wish I could remember the um,
the actual name of the documentary,
but it was a BBC documentary.
They did.
They did on him.
It was really interesting stuff.
And part of it,
he talked to one of the guys who
testified against Nixon and uh,
this guy was like in deep,
deep trouble before the tapes came out.
And then the tapes came out and,
and exonerated him and prove that what
he was saying was true.
But yeah,
a hundred was talking to him and
interviewing this guy and just shows
you,
um,
the times then like we're so much more
sinister and what the government was
capable of doing like in many ways had
been sort of Defang.
Yeah.
Hm.
Well,
I mean,
yeah,
they,
they can't break,
they can't get away with as much easy
shit.
Right.
Like maybe they don't have fangs,
but now they have tentacles.
Right.
So it's like a Japanese sit monster
situation,
like drones,
things along the long,
they have drones and I mean,
you know they have facebook.
Yeah.
So they can create 11,000 fake profiles
on facebook and send out friend requests
and now they know where everybody is.
Who's got their shit marked public.
You know,
they know when you're in the valley,
they know when you're at Burger King of
they're really looking out for you
though.
I'll do really fallen,
you know?
No,
I mean most of this data is bullshit
that they can never use.
But,
but they're accumulating it cause
they're,
I mean,
they're like Marma sets.
Like if you ever see Marma sets at the
zoo,
put something colorful up against the
glass and you got their attention and
our personal details,
although completely fucking worthless
and useless and boring.
It's interesting to somebody.
And so they want that shit.
They want to know who we're calling.
They're obsessed with that stuff because
they're curious because there are people
and so they collect it thinking we might
get a use for this or we might figure
out that somebody is a terrorist and
then we'll get everybody the day call
and then they hang on to all this other
stuff.
Cause that might be useful to,
they're just hoarders.
Like they're creepy hoarders.
Right.
And it's under the guise that one day
you might commit a crime.
Yeah.
One day we might need this so we're
gonna keep this.
That's what a hoarder things.
Well it's not really just hoarding cause
it's,
you're,
you're hoarding other people's stuff.
Right.
I mean it really is other people's
personal data,
which we haven't really,
we haven't really made the concession
that if I use email or if I make phone
calls or if I sent texts,
the government has all this,
we haven't made that concession.
Yeah.
Right.
No,
but it seems to be a reality.
It is reality.
Yeah.
But no one has agreed to that yet.
And they're just like,
ah,
freedom.
Need it for freedom at well.
And every time something like that goes
to court in an actual court as opposed
to their Pfizer courts where we're not
even allowed to know what they're asking
for.
When they go in regular court,
they lose,
but then they just go and do it in a
secret court that lets them do whatever
the fuck they want.
We'll also,
do you know how many times terrorist
attacks have been stopped by a tapping
into people's phones and reviewing
people's emails?
I'm going to guess is zero.
I would say zero.
Yeah.
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna go with zero.
I mean maybe one or two.
But you know what they like to do?
That's adorable.
They like to create terror scenarios.
Can we pay attention to those when they
talk a guy in the blowing something up,
give him a bomb on a rest and when he
tries to detonate the bomb because the
bomb wasn't real in the first place.
Yeah.
They used to do that to black panthers
and everybody in the sixties and
seventies well they used to love that.
Yeah.
And that was another thing that we
learned about the Nixon administration
with the terms of the civil rights
movement and in terms of the antiwar
movement.
Yeah.
This is it.
This is the,
this is the actual video itself.
Two friends to help stage
man got a raw deal.
So it's Bill Murray and his brother
who's also an actor.
Forgot his brother's name.
Chad.
We're going to ask him on omnibus.
Brian.
Brian doing my
ass.
Nixon.
Pardon us now more than ever,
the meeting in Beverly Hills isn't a
runaway success.
Total attendance of three.
That's the voice.
I
didn't forgive him.
And why
did it change your mind?
Yeah,
your speech,
the excitement.
I'm wearing that shirt.
Everything surrounding my mind is being
changed tonight.
Serious dude.
Seriously.
The scientologists,
they were watching that they're going
fuck wheel.
We could've got that guy.
We kind of got that guy now Nixon's got
him shit.
So that was what,
1978 yeah.
That's hilarious.
So it's many years after Watergate.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
Well they can't do that anymore.
But this whole email thing,
the Clinton email thing,
that's,
that's bizarre.
That's a bizarre one.
You know what their problem is?
What they did Whitewater and like the
Clintons beat him at Whitewater.
Right?
Even though he fucking pardoned people
that worked for him,
who did time,
they beat Whitewater.
The Whitewater was,
a lot of people think it's Watergate.
Okay.
When you're a little,
when you're in government,
you're privy to some things about where
roads might go or where electricity
might be routed.
You just get information and if you do
that stuff,
you could make real estate investments.
You can't profit from stuff like that.
That would be wrong.
But what if your wife was a consultant?
Oh,
that's not exactly how Whitewater went
down,
but that is how most of the corrupt
politicians that you see operate,
their wives have bullshit jobs and the
bribes are funneled in through that in
substantial part.
And so it could be a green lighting
something or it could be,
but yeah,
it's just,
it was just a real estate scandal and it
was probably just real estate
investments that went bad and their
books probably we're not in order.
So then they had to keep their mouth
shut.
They probably weren't really fucking
around that much.
What?
What's really fascinating know there's
one that's more obvious and more blatant
that no one bats an eye on.
And that's the Dick Cheney Halliburton
connection.
Well,
yeah.
I mean it's not family and it's not
marriage,
but when you look at the fact that this
guy was a ceo of Halliburton,
then how Britain gets these no bid
contracts for billions of dollars and
elected officials are supposed to suck,
kind of sequester their assets and
trusts a blind trusts so that they don't
really know if they're benefiting their
ownership interest in Halliburton or
Kellogg Brown.
No,
it's bullshit.
It's bullshit.
You're supposed to just pretend like you
don't own it,
and if you put it on paper in a blind
trust meant to benefit you and your
assigns,
you technically no longer own it.
Well,
let's just,
let's just be like the most optimistic
possible.
Let's say Dick Cheney didn't profit from
how Burton having all these no bid
contracts and he's still,
but he's hooked up a buddy.
Yeah.
I mean,
either way it's these,
he used to work there,
man.
He used to be the CEO and then he,
and he hooked him up with selling $48
cases of soda.
48 bucks.
Well,
it would cost a lot of money to get soda
to Iraq in his defense.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
it does not get it.
Put It on a plane,
going to hire someone to carry it.
I know.
And for that they could have built a
fucking Coca Cola plant.
Yeah.
But you don't want to cultural
appropriation,
you know,
go over there.
Cultural appropriation,
super bad.
Now that's over there with Coca Cola.
That's colonialism.
I think that is,
it's technically called.
It's just,
it's amazing that they pulled that off
and that's not under investigation,
but Whitewater,
which is,
you know,
fucked up real estate venture.
Yeah.
Like 4 million bucks worth of real
estate versus owl.
Know $1 trillion that may be incentive
to go to war.
Maybe incentive,
do certain actions that caused massive
loss of life.
Well they,
I mean they thought they were going to
win and make a nice chunk of change.
That's crazy.
Shit spun out of control and they ended
up making a lot of money and that's
real.
Like what is the movie going to be like
that we're going to vet evidently,
evidently eventually watch like there's
going to be a movie in maybe 10 or 15
years where it shows the,
the madness that was the original Iraq
war and the call to all these people
that there was weapons of mass
destruction and people a testifying to
him and then realizing it was bullshit.
Like Oh,
all the chaos involved and all the the
behind the scenes shit.
Like someone's going to do a bad ass
movie.
Like I'll put tune Oliver Stone style
movie about that war.
It's common,
right?
Yeah,
probably.
I mean they've done the hurt locker.
They done zero dark 30.
They did a Tina fey one in Afghanistan.
Um,
Tina fey.
Yeah,
the comedy.
Yeah.
She's a comedy and Afghanistan called
WTF.
I think this is real.
Yeah.
Whisky Tango,
Foxtrot.
Is it been out yet?
Just came out a couple of months ago.
There's too many movies.
That's the problem is there.
There are literally too many movies to
watch because they don't stop making
movies and you can never watch all the
movies that have already been made.
So it's like being in debt but still
buying shit.
There's no way you're going to catch up
on the great movies.
Yeah.
I can't watch all the superhero movies
that come out.
There's too many of them.
I'm done.
I think I'm done.
They just too,
they're too obvious.
Yeah.
I want more watchmen.
You know,
that was,
that was a real fucking superhero movie.
Like that was a great movie that I want
more of those come on people.
Yeah.
You know?
I haven't,
that's like the last time I saw a
superhero movie that felt like it grew
up with me.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Did you read it before?
Did you know anything about it but
nothing new.
Nothing helps that.
Yeah.
Because maybe it would be disappointed
if I had read the stuff.
They think they're fucking up your,
that is a problem.
That's a problem if you're a hardcore
fan.
I remember in squad looks interesting
cause I've never seen,
I didn't read that shit.
But it's cool to see a bunch of villains
get together and,
hmm.
I've never seen him do.
Yeah,
that'd be cool.
It looks,
it looks really fascinating.
It looks like what's going to be really
dark and creepy and should maybe be fun.
It's totally possible.
That could be something like that
watching it.
Yeah,
but I think watchman's my favorite
superhero movie I think.
Hmm.
What's yours?
I was just trying to remember like I
remember when I saw the avengers the
first one,
right?
A couple of years ago when I first came
out and they'd fucked up New York and
everyone looked like that was awesome.
But it also could have been,
it was the first time we saw the
conglomeration of all the superheroes
together.
I could go back and watch it now.
I'm probably have different thoughts on
it.
Right.
Because if,
and if you do another one,
what we already know,
they get together,
like the whole charm of them getting
together for the first time it's been
worn off and how you're going to get the
hook to listen to you get the fuck out
here,
bitch.
I didn't buy any of that.
I'm like,
he's not going to listen.
That's why he left.
He's sad.
He's gone.
You can't find them now that he was the
best Hawk though that dude.
What's that?
Yeah,
that's the best talk movie I think.
yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
He was full on bill bixby.
Mark Ravello is a bad ass act.
Like he,
I believe that he was smart enough to
create the kind of,
you know,
conditions that would lead to him being
the hulk
and he's,
and he plays it like,
so yeah.
Like it was like a guy,
like when Eric Bond and Norton did it,
it,
they kind of missed the point of like,
now you're,
you know,
you're a guy who turns into the Hawk
like a lot.
You're fucking sick of it.
Like it's not cool anymore.
Right.
You're just like,
God fucking dammit.
I'm the fucking hall could like,
it's,
you know,
it was like being an alcoholic,
like blacking out and waking up in
Tijuana.
That's the hulks life.
And then he asked to move on.
Like it's frustrating and like he played
that frustration really well.
You know what the number one problem
with all of the hulk movies and all the
whole comic books are?
Number one problem is pants.
Yeah.
What the fuck is going on?
Those pants would not survive.
He's so much bigger.
Yeah.
Then Mark Rufallo.
And those pants stretched to fit his
gigantic ass.
Just huge thighs.
Yeah.
But the shirts off a related story to
today.
I just typed in the hawk on Google.
There's a guy,
he's going to fight isis.
He looks like the hug.
Oh,
this guy's going to fight isis.
He looks like a gorilla.
He's like,
that's the hairiest guy.
Is he a Persian Hawk man?
That guy was huge.
He wants to fight isis.
Does he know they have guns?
Giant 24 stone bodybuilder.
I don't know how much that is.
I think a stone is 13 pounds.
Is that right?
Google?
Yeah.
24 how the fuck did you get that big at
24 hello?
Long.
I've been doing steroids.
The giant man with a fierce as a cult
following on instagram where he posts
what he does best.
Weightlifting.
This is just a guy that wants attention
and they're giving him attention.
This is so silly.
He's got a stick his head back and
flexes traps and that's how he's going
to fight isis.
I don't think that's going to work.
I mean,
he could probably throw tennis balls
hard enough to kill someone.
Probably throw like five pound weights.
I don't think he'd kill anybody with a
tennis ball,
you know?
I mean maybe like choke them.
I mean if you get it right in their
mouth,
even if you get it right in their mouth,
you'd have to hold it in there.
I take them breathe through their nose.
Yeah.
And then you have to like cover their
nose and that would be what kills him.
I have,
I have to rework my plan to kill a bunch
of people because they,
it involve tennis balls and I realize
it's not gonna work.
It's not going to work.
I'm going to work,
but you can get fucked up by the tennis
ball.
You'd probably get some nice cte from a
head shot to the temple,
but like one of those,
uh,
tennis machines,
it serves American gladiator.
Blop.
Blop like if you see how fast one of
those,
like,
uh,
who's like the best male Federer is that
the guy is the guy's name that did,
I think they're getting 108 hundred,
880 miles an hour with a tennis ball.
Yeah.
Imagine catching that on the nose.
Yup.
Yeah.
You're going to get some cte.
You get some sparks will fly.
You got to lose some memories.
You're going to get a black guy like
George Bush hundred and 63 is the
fastest.
Ooh,
that's fast.
Yeah.
God Damn.
That's fast.
And his ball hitting in the template 163
miles an hour.
And what is a golf ball then?
Golf ball is probably even faster.
Right?
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
for sure.
Cause it's,
it's cuts the hair better too,
right.
Can hit off of a solid piece of metal
instead of just some strings.
Right,
right,
right.
And it's also getting hit today with
late fees.
Crazy flexi polls that have,
you know,
they,
they have a certain amount of carbon
fiber in them and they know exactly how
to 211 yeah.
Whoa,
wait,
she even,
yeah,
because the arm is loving.
Like my friend Ryan got hit in the head,
Ryan Parsons shout out to Ryan Parsons,
he got hit in the head with a,
a a golf ball,
a line drive.
Fucking teed him in the head and he said
he was,
he was fucked up for like six months on
official to 37
Jesus Christ.
What's his name?
Ryan winther.
Yup.
Jesus Christ.
That guy had some ass in that shot to
show that again,
we'll call the ass that guy.
I've gotten that shot and maybe that's
the secret.
Like everybody else works out the
shoulders and he's just like,
Nah man,
it's all in.
Well he's a big dude too,
like with his thighs.
And all that shit,
but watch this,
watch this way,
put that ass in there so it spin.
Tiger's back is all fucked up.
You can't even play it now because
there's all the torque he's put on his
back over the years.
Really through all his powers come from.
Ah,
they said that his stance and his stroke
were unconventional.
So in the unconventional stance and
stroke,
I don't know if this is true or not,
but did that put any pressure whatsoever
on his spine in some weird way to that?
Yet the amount of twist he was killing
the ball.
I mean,
he also may have,
may or may not have been canceling
anything.
I don't know him.
I don't know as doctors,
but
are they testing him?
I would have to be now really the test
people for golf,
for golf,
there's so much money.
When we put up those,
the top 10 earners the other day for,
I think we're doing the fight companion.
I had switched the,
uh,
the amount of money they make from their
sport to the amount of money they make
from endorsements that three of the top
four are golfers they make,
oh,
all of them make over $50 million a year
in endorsements are expensive products
or endorsing.
Yeah,
well,
it's not just that,
it's the people that are endorsing them.
Usually a run by golfers like,
like big time business investors.
Dave fucking love making meetings on
golf courses.
Yeah.
It's a point of focus and it's also a
point of a recreation because they
gamble,
you know,
and they'll make deals with each other
on golf courses.
So they have like tiger woods
representing them or Roger Federer or
der Der der Der,
whatever his name is.
One of those dudes.
When those bad ass golfers do it,
they,
you know,
they feel like they're cool.
Like it makes the company cooler
probably good for business.
They'll do a couple ads and then
they'll,
uh,
don't make them come out a couple of
times.
She like golf aren't their friends?
What's that?
Two of them are not three words,
but a Roger Federer is making 60.
He's a tennis player.
The Lord.
And then Lebron is 54.
Tiger still up there though.
And he is barely played in the last
couple of years.
He made 45 million in endorsements last.
That's incredible.
And you know what's really incredible
about it too,
is that like he went crashing to the
ground and then still by the weight of
his name,
more than his accomplishments posts,
scandal,
he's bounced back up to 45 million a
year and look at what he made from,
from actual playing.
Yeah.
It made less like 300,000,
it says.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
Look at Mickelson.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
I mean that,
that really is incredible that he's made
that much money.
Wow.
What a,
it's amazing how much money those
fucking coffers make.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
I mean,
he,
yeah,
even though he made almost nothing
dollars playing golf last year,
and then 45 million dot.
Phil Mickelson,
look at that guy number three with 52
point $9 million and 50 million of it in
endorsements.
That is insane.
So He's a super successful golfer.
2 million.
2.9 million in winnings.
Winning tournaments either.
Oh,
really?
Might've won a couple if not at all last
year.
Oh,
okay.
Second,
third,
fourth,
fifth place.
So is he just a super famous guy showing
up too?
Yeah,
he's been good.
He's been a great golfer for a long
time.
Wow.
And how would this Northern Ireland Guy,
rory mcilroy Mcelroy Mcelroy,
the new young guns,
Mcelroy homeboy.
Nobody.
I mean I've never heard of him.
If you heard of Mcelroy?
No I have no.
Okay.
Homeboy made $35 million.
So,
and endorsements.
Golf is nuts.
What another game?
It's interesting how many rich people
have attached themselves to that.
What's the dumbest sport that somebody
made a lot of money and curling
endorsement.
How much you think they make curly?
Yeah,
look for the top curler.
Crows getting mad when you bring this
up.
By the way,
there's a bunch of people in Canada got
really pissed at me for talking shit
about curling.
Think I actually got pissed.
Not unironically auto racing.
It's pretty bad ass though.
Yeah.
Well earnhardt you'd think earnhardt
would be cleaning up way more than
everybody else.
Formula One.
Oh,
auto racing is amazing.
I mean that,
that to me is one of the craziest things
to dedicate your life to those formula
one guys.
My God,
it's really,
it,
it's interesting how that doesn't really
fly over here,
but,
but yet we do like fast cars.
Like why don't we like Nascar but we
don't like Formula One.
Um,
I think NASCAR,
well I didn't ask our start from a
bootlegging races.
Yeah.
So that's pretty fucking real.
It's pretty cool.
Pretty dope actually.
Yeah.
So it's like a formula one doesn't have
that kind of fucking backstory.
It's like these to have to have a trunk,
whereas Formula One is just like really
a race car and Nascar vehicles,
they had to be able to store whiskey and
um,
while they're avoiding the fas.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Like I think the beauty of that is kind
of like for Nascar,
it sorta has to be a car that you could
get,
you know,
like it's gotta be based on a car that
the rest of us could get.
Yeah.
You know,
like when somebody just fucking crushing
it in a chevy.
Yeah.
Whereas opposed to when somebody's like,
it's a goddamn 14 foot needle.
Right.
Like the,
he's on it.
Yeah.
And then there's a,
the guy sitting in the cockpit which is
in the center and he's exposed.
Yeah.
You know,
those,
uh,
Ayrton Senna videos of him when he was
at the top of the heap in a,
in racing and watching from his
perspective,
like if you ever seen some of those
videos,
no,
dude,
it's like when you see the video from a
perspective of a person actually driving
the car,
it's phenomenal.
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing what a us,
a fast,
insane experience.
It is to be in a formula one car and
make those turns like that to me is one
of the most exciting things to watch.
And all of sports because they are just,
especially if you could look at it from
their point of view,
I mean you,
you're grabbing the cushions of the
couch going,
fuck,
fuck.
Yeah.
Cause they're making these split second
decisions.
They have to take these tight turns or
avoiding people around them.
They're trying to cut corners.
Like look at this guy,
look at this fucking car.
Listen to this.
Now we're watching this video.
Uh,
Jamie,
what's the name of this video?
It says a first time ever.
I level camera.
Formula One.
This is probably what I've seen online.
Like
this looks like so much God damn fun.
Oh yeah.
This guy's fucking in this thing
and he doesn't have a windshield.
He,
this little tiny windshield that's about
six inches long or six inches high
rather.
And he's got just goggles on and a face
mask and the whole deal and a helmet.
But he's essentially exposed in this
super rocket ship.
It's got a controlled explosion going on
flying around this track with amazing
sounds.
Yeah.
It just
says they'd do up to five g's and Nascar
get up,
gets up to only to,
oh,
I could imagine.
Oh yeah,
five Jesus is insane.
You probably have to have an insanely
strong neck.
Yeah,
well I think your head's stuck in place
by some gadget now.
I mean it definitely is in a nascar
because a lot of people got really
fucked up.
Oh really?
Little correction there.
See that?
It's a quick move with the hand,
but who the ass and kicked out a little
bit on them dude.
Then fucking knobs on that car and
saying like,
donate what those buttons do it.
Yeah.
What?
No,
it is the green number two knob do well
those,
well those uh,
all those lights that go across,
those are indicating the rpms cause they
have those in some cars.
So when you see his light go and it goes
from green,
like before,
you can see it in better,
uh,
images.
But he has like see there those lights.
That's like to let him know most likely
what is our rpms are at and when it's,
when he's in danger of blowing his
engine.
I don't know if these guys have
regulators on their engine.
Gay.
This is probably stupid question.
Car people are going crazy cause like,
um,
if you buy a new car today,
they have rev limiters.
So you'll get to a certain rpm is where
you could fucking torture engine and
it'll back you off.
God Damn,
that looks fun though.
I get excited just watching that
adrenaline.
Yeah.
The thrill of the chase and what else?
What else?
Mike Schmidt.
Victory.
Yeah.
So you did this for 10 years,
man.
And then a decided,
fuck this,
I'm going to be a comic.
Ah Yeah.
Well I was doing that on the side,
but at one point I was like,
hm,
it's,
they're never going to listen to this.
So I guess I'm just going to go to tell
jokes.
Wow.
So you tried to enact some sort of
reform or you tried to at least say what
the fuck's going on?
Yeah.
But you know,
they don't listen.
So do you bring any of this up in your
act?
No.
Now because it's really depressing.
Yeah.
Right.
Like it's,
you know,
to figure out a way to make that funny.
Yeah.
Cause they like it's,
it's happening right now.
Like right now somebody since we started
talking is getting something onto a
computer record cause we used to not
have computer records and so now
somebody is getting a computer record
that they shoplifted so there goes all
their entry level employment fucking
for,
I don't know,
three,
four years.
Good luck with have fun
filing for disability that that just
happened to somebody else and it's going
to happen again in a couple more
minutes.
Like it just,
it's,
it's not the sensational cases that get
you,
it's the grinding.
It's the every single guy gets a little
more than some,
you know it's just a gradual creep.
Like mothers against drunk driving keeps
bringing the law like the legal limit
for alcohol down and down and down.
But they don't change the study that
they have the cops point to to say why
the field sobriety tests work.
So like in the 70s the horizontal gaze
Nystagmus test would say that a
horizontal gaze Nystagmus sets in prior
to 45 degrees.
Only if you're above a point to or,
but then they redid the study and now
his 0.15 and then they read it.
Explain what that means.
So if,
if you've ever seen somebody get pulled
over by an officer and then the officer
has a bright light and they're on the
side of the road as a bunch of cars go
past like fucking strobe lights.
So they'll have you look at a pen and
then they'll trace it like this.
And so prior to 45 degrees,
you're,
I should track very smoothly.
If I move it quickly,
if I move it slowly,
there might be a little bit of Stutter,
but I'm supposed to do the test quickly.
And then if I put it there and hold it,
I look for a little bit of aggravated
Nystagmus.
And so the national highway traffic and
safety authority or National Highway
Traffic Safety Board,
uh,
put together this,
this one,
and then the one leg stand and the walk
and turn test.
And they say that you can tell if
somebody's drunk,
if they fail these tests,
the tests aren't accurate at all.
And they were originally picked in the
70s when the limit was higher.
And they would say,
these tests will only detect somebody
above 0.2 and then they,
when they changed the legal limit,
they didn't change the test.
So remember in the 70s your eyes weren't
going to quiver over here unless you're
above 0.2 but now in the 80s they're
telling cops that the eyes will quiver
above 0.1 and now here in the two
thousands they're telling them cops that
the eyes will quiver at that point above
0.08
so they've changed the data to
correspond with the new laws.
They didn't change the data.
Even they just said,
did it still works?
Even though the point of that test was
to pick people up above two point above,
a much higher limit above.
They're looking for people at 0.15
so not,
not the data,
but the,
the,
the number that they use to determine
whether or not you're,
you're,
you're drunk or sober.
How did they know the method?
Right?
Know what I'm saying is it's not a real
test.
Right.
But they lowered the limit,
right?
Like the lemon,
it used to be 2.0 yup.
And now what is it now?
One Point six 0.0 8.08 sorry.
Yeah.
Um,
what did they use to determine?
I mean if,
if,
if that was what was originally
established that you had to do,
the field sobriety would indicate
that some was about how when once the
limit got lowered,
how do they,
how do they keep that same test?
Like what are they used to?
They just didn't care.
But they,
what do they say in that?
The booklet?
Like you can tell it so they just say it
just change the number.
You could see it at 0.08 with no data to
back it up and alive.
My Dad's got the fucking manual from the
70s he's got the manual from the 80s got
the manual from the 90s and got the
manual from today.
Yeah,
it seems so they don't even care.
But um,
but you assume though,
right?
Wouldn't you that if someone fails that
test,
that test would indicate their 2.0 will.
They'll definitely 0.8 then.
So really you don't have to change it
well,
but scientifically they probably should.
Well they established like when,
but they're using it for proof that
somebody has a 0.08 right.
When it's only effective to prove that
their 0.15 or above for example.
Yeah.
So that's,
this test is designed for people at 0.15
to fail and they're saying people at
Point Oh eight or failing it.
The thing is though,
so they just don't wait.
I mean when you,
when they test them with a breathalyzer,
so they just barely make it illegal,
but they still fail the field sobriety
tests.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
So it's subjective.
The tests are subjective and we pretend
that Wa,
you know like one leg stand,
it's seven potential.
Qs is somehow an effective way of
looking at somebody and tell them if
they're drunk,
it's fucking eyeball.
Now look at them would,
if somebody tells passes a test,
like what have you pulled them over?
They pass a test,
but then they don't want to take any
further test.
It's like,
look,
I just,
I passed your test,
I did all your shit.
I don't want to take any breathalyzer.
In most of the states of the union,
you're required to give a sample of your
blood,
breath or urine.
And if you don't,
then they'll charge you with refusal.
That's a fourth amendment,
fifth amendment violation if ever there
was one.
But because the police,
when most of their arguments,
it's mostly okay,
they had to go isolation.
Well because you can't be forced to give
evidence against yourself and they want
you to give evidence from you that
they'll use to convict you.
And they want to do that at the scene of
the crime with no legal representation.
It's not like you have your lawyer there
and you say,
Hey,
Mr,
they're saying here,
they're saying we could only prove that
you drove drunk if you give us your
fucking blood,
so now give us your blood.
Uh,
so they used to be duped,
forcing blood draws and doing that stuff
without warrants.
And a couple of years ago,
the supreme court was like,
you guys need to get warrants for this
stuff.
And,
but the thing is now they get warrants.
But isn't it problematic that it takes a
long time to get a warrant?
I mean,
how long does it take to get a warrant?
Like say if a guy gets pulled over,
you say,
oh,
this dude's drunk.
Hey Man,
give me some blood.
No,
I'm not gonna give you any blood.
All right,
we got to call the cops.
10 minutes.
You,
they can be faster.
Really?
Yeah.
Tell us that it was those warrants or
files.
Yeah.
No,
like some jurisdictions warrants do take
time,
but other places you can be issued a
warrant over the telephone.
But what if he gets to make a phone call
and it calls Governor Clinton?
Governor Clinton says,
Oh yeah,
you don't have to let him call you,
loosen your domain.
I know a guy who knows God well
let just let them dry.
We can take the test in a little while.
He's not prepared when we need to go
over this paperwork first.
But yeah,
so those tests are bullshit and they use
them because it's really,
it's just the officer needs to be able
to sit up there and say that you did
some shit wrong.
Okay.
So let me say this a,
so if you are,
you are a criminal defense attorney.
You get a guy who's on a drunk driving
case,
um,
the cops busted them,
but they busted him by forcing him to
give blood.
How do you defend that?
First you look at the stop.
So you find out how long they were
following him and if how much a good
driving and how much bad driving they
viewed.
So for that you would,
I mean,
if you want to do a good job,
let's say you're defending a very,
very rich person who has the money to
pay for this Bill Gates.
You're defending Bill Gates.
So you're going to order the squad video
and then you're going to open records
requests,
the radio communications and the
teletypes from the squad car to everyone
else because they might be saying
something racist.
Or they might be saying something.
So you pull the teletypes and then
you're going to want the conduct records
of all the officers and then you're
going to want to find out if you can
pursue any administrative appeals of a
temporary suspension of the license.
So you're going to do that because two
reasons.
One,
you don't want your client's license
suspended,
and two,
you might also find some things because
you might be able to get a couple of
records and forced the cops to show up
and drop some paperwork off for you that
you have in advance.
Then you're going to look at the stop
and you're going to file a motion saying
that the stop was illegal because of x,
Y,
and z.
Then you'll argue about the bail
conditions.
Then you'll order,
you'll,
you'll wait about six to eight weeks for
the results for the blood test results
to come back as soon as they come back
or even before you file a motion that
you've been working on saying that the
blood test results are problematic
because they were illegally drawn or the
facility is not accredited or the person
who administered the test is not
accredited or the machine has not been
maintained properly.
At the same time you order the reports
for the machine maintenance because
you'll find that when they do the
blanks,
sometimes they're not when they run them
through a gas chromatograph mass
spectrometer or whatever system they're
going to use when they do these samples.
So I mean these are guys with technical
college to degrees or bachelor's degrees
that have taken a six to eight week
course and they might be pretty good at
it,
but there's still fuck ups.
And so sometimes things come in and
they're not sealed.
Sometimes there's a problem with the
vacuum cleaner that they use for the
blood draw and sometimes the,
sometimes the stuff that they put in the
Vacu tainer in advance to keep the blood
from coagulating is expired or has a
problem with it.
And you have to check that out.
So if you have an extremely rich
defendant,
every thing from your fucking eye color
is in question.
Basically the,
yeah,
every step of the way where anything
happens,
you have a question about it.
So wisdom machine properly and who
program these fucking machines?
Can I see the code?
Because if I can't see the code to the
machine,
Gee,
we can't say at all if this machine
works,
if we don't know the code.
And for a lot of these devices,
the code is proprietary and they won't
give you the code.
So they won't allow you to know how some
of the machines that they use to watch
you work.
So you can't,
as an attorney at war as a defendant,
you can't actually point to a problem
and say,
see,
you didn't carry the one and you doubled
my fucking result.
Or,
you know,
like this shows that it was,
I'm patient four,
eight,
six,
three,
this is for this.
They sometimes they won't give you those
records or,
and so then you have a problem.
You hope actually that they don't give
you shit because when they do give you
shit,
it's proof that it's generally in
working order.
But when shit comes late,
it means there's a fucking problem.
And that's when you know you smell blood
and you start to chase that down.
You know,
so like,
and then,
and then the next point you do is you go
and you try and settle the case and you
think here are the guidelines.
Because most out of Uis guideline
offenses,
most places,
because people get a first one and then
they get a second and a third and a
fourth and fifth.
And even though the penalties go up,
it's crazy.
Cause the more out of Uis people have,
the less dangerous they tend to be
during those adobe wys like sevens,
it'll hit park cars all fucking day,
but they don't kill people.
Two's kill people.
First offense,
drunk drivers,
they fucking kill people.
So,
so people just get better at drunk
driving is absolutely they do.
It's horrifying.
But yeah,
they do make sense.
Perfect.
Yeah.
With everything in line and they take
certain roads and they drive slower,
they compensate for it.
They're not,
I mean,
they're used to being drunk.
They're alcoholics,
you know?
Dude,
that was terrifying.
Yeah.
This,
this surgical precisely this to the way
you broke down the process of,
and now what is the difference between a
rich person and someone who gets an
attorney assigned to them by the state.
Okay.
Um,
you want to get,
I mean,
you want to get like pick a crime.
Well,
let's use the same crime.
Okay.
Someone who's drunk driving because,
Oh,
poor guy.
All right,
let's pull over and you're handling
them.
Okay.
We can't do all those things.
You want to know you can't do those
things.
So what you have to do is you've got to
do everything that you can do on that
list because in 90% of those,
Kate,
of those times,
or maybe even 99% of the time,
those avenues will be completely
fruitless.
Those won't get you shit because route,
you know,
stops routinely.
Rubber stamped warrants,
rubber stamp.
And the machines are generally agreed to
be in working order.
And a lot of places there are statutes
meant to protect the you from even being
able to get this information.
So Eh,
but things that really do work are like
bring their family to sentencing because
most people who are convicted of crimes
had been convicted of a compliment
crimes and nobody shows up for them
anymore and nobody gives a shit about
them.
And what's going to happen is they're
going to go in and they're going to do
their time and they're going to get out
and nobody's going to give shit about
them.
Then they're going to do something else
and then you get to go back in.
But if you've got a family there,
the judge can see,
will somebody still cares about this
asshole?
Somebody still thinks there's some good
in them.
I bet there's some good in them.
And I got a couple people who are
willing to show up and watch him take
his medicine,
watch him see that,
watch him admit he fucked up and
promised to try to be better.
So these guys are kind of on our side.
These guys are going to try and help
this guy not come back here and that
will shorten your sentence.
If you have supportive people in your
side of the room,
that will shorten your sentence.
Um,
yeah.
Things that are open to rich people like
you want it.
I mean all almost all expert witnesses
are horse.
Like people.
People would ask me like,
well how do you like how do you choose
an expert?
And I'll be like,
I just,
I just ask everybody else what kind of
expert they use.
And they were like,
what if the expert says something you
don't want them to say,
I'm like,
that does not happen.
And they're like,
do you tell the expert what to say?
No.
The expert knows if the prosecution or
defense or plaintiff or defendant calls
them.
They know which side you're on.
And miraculously,
every fucking expert I've ever offered
money to,
to give me their honest and completely
unbiased opinion has said I was right.
What are the odds?
Every single fucking one.
He must really know how to pick quality
attorneys,
I guess quality,
professional experts,
quality experts.
But yeah,
what I'm saying is like they're just,
they're whores,
and then we'll say anything.
And there's a business in being a horse.
So like if you're looking for a guy
who's a a DNA expert or you're looking
for a guy who was a chemical expert,
like you know the guy to call because
other friends who have used them on
similar cases.
Yep.
And,
and there are guys there,
I mean they're all whores.
There are some guys who are solid
because whores do tell the truth.
You know,
like horse do important work,
but they are horse and you should never
forget that.
That's something I think Republicans get
when they argue about climate change.
That's why they don't listen to the
fucking billion scientists on one side
because they know like,
oh yeah,
you can just buy a study.
They don't realize that these are the
studies that weren't bought and that you
should actually believe these,
but they just,
they know how it is because they've seen
that happen over and over and over
again.
Like Monsanto by studies and they marry
studies and attorneys do the same thing.
They get,
they hire an expert and miraculously the
expert just agrees with them every
fucking time.
I don't know how it works.
Like I would expect that I would hire an
expert sometime and they would say,
you know,
Schmidt,
you're wrong.
Uh,
these fingerprints are a match,
but then never know.
Now,
do you think that this is because I
mean,
are you communicating with these guys
beforehand?
Like when you,
when you hire an expert,
do you have any,
I never ever said anything to any of
them about how I wanted them to just say
anything.
And how much do you pay in these guys?
Like say if you bring a guy who was a
fingerprints guy,
if you,
okay,
if you're public defender's office,
you can pay no more than a grand or
1500,
I think it is.
And you got to pay it out of your own
pocket and then they'll reimburse you in
like six months after the trials done.
So you don't have experts functionally
if you got money and expert can run yet
15 grand.
Okay.
And,
but it depends on the type of case.
If it's medical or if it's an end state,
the state will fly.
Like this is a beautiful thing.
If you throw piss on a guard,
do you know it's hard for them to tell
that it's pissed,
but it's a felony in most jurisdictions
to throw urine on uh,
on security personnel at a prison.
It's called gassing,
but it costs extra money because the,
there are actually very few experts who
can say that this is urine.
Okay.
This person through on them,
like the test for urine versus it's
just,
it costs money to fly someone to say
that this guy did throw piss on this
guard and here's this scientist who can
say beyond a reasonable doubt that was
pis.
They really have to fly someone from
Philadelphia sometimes to Wisconsin to
say that was piss.
That's how fucked up our system is.
That to prove beyond a reasonable doubt
that it was pissed in a felony trial.
We need a scientist,
so no wonder they're fucking horse
because that's the shit we put.
Like we make them privy or part of our
little stupid disputes like that
continuously and it warps them just the
same way it warps everyone else.
Ooh,
good God.
What a bleak picture.
Well,
but the important thing to remember is
most people are outside and having fun
most of the time.
Most of the time,
but not important because what if
something happens and you happen to be
driving while black and all of a sudden
you're in the same situation that you
described,
right?
Where you wind up getting extracted from
this beautiful outside world.
Yeah.
Well stuck in it.
That's something that we all have to do
something about.
And if anybody's got ideas,
well I
think talking about it is huge.
Um,
I wasn't aware of it to the extent.
I mean obviously I have zero knowledge
of what it's like in Madison,
Wisconsin,
other than the few times I've visited.
So hearing you describe it and
especially zero knowledge of what it's
like inside the criminal justice system.
But hearing you describe it,
it's,
uh,
it's pretty disheartening.
It's,
it's,
it's atrocious.
It's,
it's scary and it seems like an
excusable.
It seems like if you're looking at the
raw data as far as like what happens to
be both the black and what happens with
her wife at first offenders,
it's garbage.
Scary.
And our best idea was teaching some
children to garden.
Oh,
I mean,
yeah.
You know,
I was at a,
in yellowstone recently and um,
it was a really beautiful,
but one of the things it was freaking me
out was that it was,
um,
created by an act of Congress in 1872.
And,
uh,
I was thinking,
good Lord,
like I'm 1872,
you know,
I was alive in 1972.
That's not that long ago.
That's fairly recently.
And then I was thinking that's only
seven years after slavery was abolished.
And then I looked it up and it's 14
years before the creation of the
gasoline powered automobile.
I'm like,
that.
This is amazing.
Like,
this is amazing how recent all this is.
Yeah.
And um,
I was talking with someone,
oh,
Byron bowers,
do you know Byron area standup comedian?
And Byron was talking about,
um,
Byron's black and he was talking about
his grandmother remembering his great
grandmother telling her about the
invention of the cotton gin.
Eli Whitney.
Yeah.
Like she was around for that.
That's fucked up.
And you know,
he was talking about different relatives
that he had,
you know,
great grandmothers and what have you
that were slaves and um,
you know,
really hits home.
We go,
that is so like for us,
we grow up.
And when,
when you were a little kid and you hear
1865,
you go,
wow,
that was fucking forever ago.
But as life goes on,
the perspective sort of comes clearer
and clearer and a focus when you
realize,
oh my God,
like that was a blink ago.
Yeah.
1965 was essentially a cultural blink
ago.
And when you look at like the history of
China or the history of England even,
I mean,
this massive long history.
And then the United States,
we know 1865 is fucking nothing.
Yeah,
we're,
I mean,
yeah,
we're really young country where there's
countries that are seven times as old as
we are and I mean
from all I got it.
I want to say one more thing about that
criminal justice system.
It's weird because yeah,
gas powered automobile electricity,
telecommunications space travel and to
slavery and we still have fundamentally
the same criminal justice system.
Why we didn't improve
on it one bit.
We added some,
we added a couple things,
but it's not fundamentally different.
It was designed,
it's the Dana Law,
it's fucking vikings used to use it and
then it became the English common law,
like what should it be?
What do you think?
Like is there an ideal system with
someone as a proposed?
No,
no.
I don't think there's an ideal system,
but I do think that right now a country
of 346 million people.
Is it that lesson?
Yeah.
There's more than 300 million counting
Mexicans.
Yeah.
They're people.
346 million?
I think so,
yeah.
What is that like?
Is that the official shout?
God dammit.
But how many illegal aliens are supposed
to be here?
Well,
none are supposed to be here.
I mean,
but allegedly.
Okay.
How many are allegedly here?
How many have been counted account of,
how am I supposed to be here by God's
law that go wherever they want and now I
think they,
I don't have a problem with immigration.
It sounds like you do know putting in
back heels.
I mean,
I think we should let everybody in wants
to come.
It's kind of the idea of the country.
Not everyone.
You don't want an orange county.
Yeah.
Want to fucking die if more people moved
there.
Oh yeah.
Well I mean for Nebraska has got room.
It does.
If you fly over the country,
you realize there's a lot of spots.
Yeah,
there's a lot of spots and we're kind of
being dicks.
Like there's some people who like,
I don't want to live in Libya and
fucking come over here.
Well,
um,
uh,
president trump's going to pull a nice
wall and stop,
stop everything.
See what I think we should do is I think
we should fucking put the feelers out,
put the vibes out.
And then if we see like a population
that gets treated like shit,
we should fucking just steal them.
Just like,
you know,
there's countries where it's illegal to
be homosexual,
but you know,
like we got room,
we should just be like,
Hey,
can you call your homos?
We'll take all every single one.
Usually they make a lot of money.
They all have discretionary income.
Cause most of the time they don't have
kids to go for the economy.
Why the fuck not,
you know,
come on over.
What do you think is going to happen if
trump becomes president and we have the
social justice warrior president of
Canada,
they're prime ministers.
Like he's there.
They're going to explore the idea of
gender neutral identity cards.
Like,
okay,
frogs.
Yeah,
he can't just like,
what do you tell the cops mister or
misses?
E what jail did we put in you?
We put you in the gender neutral jail or
do you go into men's?
Do you have a deck?
Dude,
can I say,
okay,
you're a guy.
I mean it is,
it's kind of juvenile that we like,
oh you murdered somebody but you have a
pain.
It's you murdered somebody but you have
a vagina.
You have to go to separate facilities.
Murderers.
Well they should because otherwise
they'll fuck.
And the crepe murder of babies,
I mean,
they're not all going to fuck.
And some of them it's kind of like,
well why do you,
why do we even care?
Cause they're going to fuck each other.
Yeah.
But dudes are gonna fuck dudes.
And that's the punishment for being in
jail.
And if you lock people up with hot
criminal girls,
then you get a porno movie.
I mean,
yeah,
that caged cheat.
You run cage t have cake.
It's just,
that's what it is.
They're just going to bang each other.
All right.
I agree with the policy then.
If,
if it results in women
in prison films.
Yeah.
It's always the guard.
So he's the female guard that gets
reduced like that Tupac Song.
Oh yeah.
Remember
when not get free.
He was seduced in the guard.
I mean,
you know,
there was a guard,
it was like some movie about a guard
that had a relationship with some guy
who was a prisoner.
This dude could apparently lie on his
back without touching his penis.
He can make his dick or rack and he
could ejaculate.
But he had time to practice.
Yeah,
but I mean that is amazing what it is.
Guy Put,
see these urban myths,
man,
it's hard to tell.
There's no camera on this dude deck,
right?
I mean,
yeah,
if he could really do it.
Did he die in prison?
Um,
I don't know.
It's a good question.
Cause if you could do that and you
didn't die in prison,
somebody probably paid you money to film
it.
All right,
let me ask you this.
When it's a subject to restitution,
do you think,
Gosh,
that guy,
I'll get off with time served plus
restitution.
If you can make Dick porn and jail,
like say if that guy didn't do anything
too terrible,
maybe just robbed a bunch of liquor
stores or something like that and all of
a sudden he's in jail and he realizes
that he's practiced by himself in the
zen room so long that he could get his
dick hard and come all over himself.
People would pay money to see that.
Yeah.
So if he starts like his own,
uh,
I,
I just,
I myself website from jail.
Webcam service makes a lot of money.
Yeah.
It gives it to the victims.
No,
I mean I think it's constructive.
I think it's helpful.
I think he should start by,
I think anyone who's interested in doing
that,
whatever correctional facility there in,
perhaps write to the judge that
sentenced you and request that you do
the same or just an opportunity.
I have no doubt that people can do that
because if someone can have a wet dream,
that means their fantasy is allowing
them to ejaculate.
Yeah.
So I think there's some people that have
done some really amazing things with
their mind,
right?
Like there's people that practice
Kundalini Yoga and they get to some
place where they can have some trance
and they have psychedelic states.
I'm not,
I believe it.
I'm not skeptical.
I mean,
I bet you could do it.
Like I bet that sounds like something
where if you practiced,
if you just waited,
cause there's dudes who just in their
pants,
when women walk up to him,
whoa.
Like this is just like a little bit more
removed.
Right.
The fact that that dude did it for the
guard.
Kapow let her know what's up.
Yeah.
This is a kind of power I'm dealing
with.
Yeah.
Like on command and salad bar must
happen because that's what I'll also
happened up in upstate New York.
When those guys get free and they,
uh,
those murders,
they tracked him to Canada.
The woman was supposed to let them out
where they escaped and the woman was
supposed to meet them outside.
Remember that?
Yup.
That was the same situation.
Homely lady.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Fairly handsome dude.
Thought were going to have relationship.
Yep.
I,
uh,
when I first started visiting prisons
for clients,
uh,
this guy who was a former,
I think it was secretary of
the Department of Corrections,
he was our criminal law professor ran us
through a whole bunch of shit we have to
watch out for when we go into prison.
And one of them was inmates trying to
seduce you.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
Even dudes.
Well they got nothing going on.
Right.
Just try it.
Yeah.
No judge.
No.
Yeah.
And I mean
the way he ran it through us like to us
was like a little crazy.
He's like,
Yep,
they're going to try to,
uh,
sexually input too.
And you,
they're going to try to walk on Zip that
flies and then we importuning.
Yeah.
Ooh,
I've never heard that word before.
I never heard anybody use that.
Yeah.
Cause he was saying that they would
unzip their flies potentially and then
take advantage of the fact that we
didn't say anything about it the next
time
to call.
Basically to get us to commit a minor
offense so that we,
or break a little rule or lead us a
little bit down the path and then next
time they would try to take their dicks
out.
Okay.
So if you don't call him out on having
his fly down,
it's an offense.
No,
no,
but it's,
it's not like a crime.
It's not like a rule violation.
Okay.
But if he's got social,
if it's,
and the,
they'll sit differently like,
ah,
like if someone sits there with their
fly open,
you know,
and it's like this and their crotches on
display,
they're letting you know they've got
some Dick for,
so they're like,
yeah,
they're like,
hey,
by the way,
there's some Dick in here.
And then next time they'll be more,
cause there's a lot of sociopath's in
prison.
Oh,
a lot.
Because a lot for a lot of people,
what it comes down to is the sentencing
because they're guilty as shit.
There's a lot of witnesses,
you know,
and they don't have,
they're not made of money.
So they can't pay some expert to write a
report saying that jail would hurt their
feelings,
which they fucking do if you have money.
Um,
it comes down to a lot of,
uh,
being able to take ownership of what
happened and what you did.
And a lot of sociopaths are in prison
because they're too stupid to listen to
how everybody else apologizes.
So sociopath's will say something like,
you know,
I'm sorry that I played a part in all of
this or you know,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not going to put myself in
situations like this anymore.
Your honor,
when they're being convicted of beating
the shit out of somebody,
they'll say,
I'm not going to put myself in
situations like this.
Sounds like they're taking ownership,
but put in a situation just means you're
one small part of this fucking
situation.
Multiple aggressors and loud noises and
rankin.
So it's,
and to somebody that is making the
apology,
it sounds like it works,
but to a room full of people that hear
nothing but apologies all day
we'd go,
oh,
he's going to be back.
And that's how,
and the judges listen for that shit very
intently.
There's ways to fuck up and apology and
the only people who fuck up,
the apologies in that specific way are
almost completely incapable of putting
themselves in anybody else's shoes and
those types of people.
And I tend to do certain types of things
where it's,
they're always out for themselves.
Me,
me,
me.
Why does he get to do that?
Why can't I do that?
Like that Shit like that child is
bullshit.
Self centered,
selfish or at all.
But they're an adult.
That's just what a sociopath is.
It's not that impressive.
It's not like,
you know,
fucking silence of the lambs or some
shit.
It's just super selfish.
Super inconsiderate of the ramifications
of their actions.
And they are just,
and they,
they don't even know how to relate to
the rest of us because they don't care.
I don't care to like,
we're just robots to,
you know,
in your experience dealing with so many
of these different people and so many
different criminals,
do you,
do you think it's a nature thing or a
nurture thing?
Nurture.
Yeah,
it's nurture.
I mean,
there are some,
some broken folks,
there's some,
some people are born evil.
You just like,
some people are born with bad kidneys,
right?
So some people were born like,
didn't they say the Jeffrey Dahmer?
It wasn't a good example.
Or of a guy who allegedly had a pretty
stable childhood with loving parents and
became a serial killer.
Yeah.
But,
but you don't know,
right?
Yeah.
Like they're going to say they beat the
shit.
Fuck them.
Like they're going to be like,
no,
we did them the same way.
A Charles Manson and Ted Bundys moms did
them.
No,
you're not going to say that.
But yeah,
I mean,
people who do that generally have kind
of similar histories.
Well,
if you think about the way a human being
could vary the way we behave,
you could be like the most beautiful,
generous kind,
caring person.
Or you could be a brutal dictator in the
Congo and chopping people's arms off.
And you could be either one of those is
still be a human being.
Yeah.
So if you,
if you think about that and you think
about the conditions that you have to
sort of adapt to and if you were growing
up at some hellacious condition,
you adapted to that helacious condition
and it is,
you are literally a product of society
now.
When you come across people like that
because you're in the criminal defense
attorney world and you have to represent
these people,
do you,
do you try to think like is there a way
to fix this guy?
I mean do you put that in your head or
do you just go and try to win?
I try.
Well,
when I get,
when I would get them to do the
apologies because one of,
I mean the thing is like for a lot of
these guys,
too many witnesses,
too much of a record.
It's coming down in his fucking apology,
right?
It's coming down to our plan for what
we're going to do and
talking with them and coming up with a
reasonable plan about what they're going
to do after jail or what they could do
instead of jail and addressing like,
why would they w they did something
wrong.
Okay.
Why was it wrong?
Like I would go through with my clients
a lot of the times if I wasn't sure that
they were getting it and I would be
like,
okay,
so you're going to have to give an
apology to the judge.
You're going to have to tell them that
what you did is wrong.
you know that it was wrong and you're
gonna have to tell him,
you know why it was wrong.
So why is it wrong to hit your
girlfriend?
Uh,
she doesn't want me to.
Well,
okay.
All right.
There's one,
uh,
when you hit your girlfriend,
what are the police have to do?
They have to show up and they have to
arrest me.
Where you nice to them?
No.
Do you think they like that?
Do you think now it would be the time to
apologize for being a dick to them when
they were just doing their jobs?
Yeah.
Okay.
But now say it in a different way.
Say it in a nice way and then I made
them say it in a nice like then you have
to really coach them through this and do
you let them know like listen to your
freedom may ride on whether or not
you're believable.
Yup.
And I most important performance,
I would tell him like you,
you're not going to lie up there.
Everything you say is going to be true.
We just need to make you fucking
recognize you for just a couple minutes.
You got to recognize this situation
cause you can't lie out there.
They hear too many lies.
They don't like lies.
Just it's like George Michael and
freedom.
Like take a lie and make it true.
A lot of times I would ask quote George
Michael,
yeah,
I did
that Song of freedom.
Yeah,
it's a good song.
It is a good song,
right?
Yeah.
Good on you for admitting that.
A lot of the people,
they shy away from giving George Michael
the props he deserves.
Yeah.
But I would use like take these lies and
make them true.
I would use that on my clients and he's
saying that,
no,
I'm a terrible.
So no,
I can't take these labs and may can
choose.
We have to.
There we go.
Um,
that's a great God damn song.
You know,
it's the best.
You can't hear it on the Youtube.
Right.
We will get pulled,
right?
Yeah.
Only we can hear it.
Well,
listen,
if you see the video,
this is the best part about that song.
That was one of those songs.
It was made by the video.
Yeah.
Because he's got it.
But God damn,
these girls are hot.
Yep.
So much hotness.
Naomi Campbell,
Christy Turlington,
some of those girls are still hanging in
there.
Yeah.
In my world.
This is a tremendous video.
Amazing what cemetery and bone structure
does for the emotions.
Beautiful.
Full Lips and looking at pretty people.
It's fucking great.
It is.
It's amazing.
But what I do is I would,
I'd be like,
so they're not going to let you out
because you don't have a job.
Right.
And you've never been in the community
with more than this for more than this
length of time without doing this.
And I'd be like,
well we can't lie to him and tell him
like I would make a list of shit that I
wish was true and I'd be like,
one of these things,
can I fucking just make true like can I
get this person to do these job
applications?
Yeah.
I could totally do that.
Like if I could bail him out for it,
like if I can get him to make his bail,
if I can get his bail low enough and
then I can get him to submit job
applications every single week.
It was a lie when I came up with it a
couple minutes ago,
but in six months when this case finally
goes in front of the judge,
he'll probably have a job and they would
like,
you just think about some shit.
You want to be true,
figure out how to make it true.
And you know,
like maybe he's got to have his kids
back or maybe he's had to have a better
relationship with his kids,
which means you start right in the
fucking letters now because in six
months have them show up.
Like just cause the thing is like,
yeah,
it's a lie if you have no intention of
making it true and we wouldn't say in an
advance,
I would just be like,
well you know,
so do you feel like you're coaching
these guys,
not just through their trial but maybe
through their understanding of the
implications of their crime as well?
What are you in some way sort of
educating them and to,
you know,
cause if they have to be honest about
it,
they have to kind of be maybe educated
about the impact of their choices.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I would,
I mean to the extent that I thought it
was appropriate,
like,
because I'm in a position of power,
you know,
emotional abuse is not proper,
like,
like abusing them,
like insulting them or something like
that.
Yeah.
Like insulting them and there's people
where you would completely want to when
salt them.
It's just not appropriate because
they're such terrible monster.
But what do you do?
It's you're in one of those situations.
Yeah,
I've had,
uh,
there's,
I've had some guys that make my skin
crawl and like I've sat next to people,
you know,
done horrible things to people where
they don't make my skin crawl and yet
these other people are just so far
beyond them in terms of like,
we don't like,
we should probably lock him up forever.
Like you can't do anything because you,
you,
you sort of have a mandate,
right?
You have to win.
I have to make them beat me.
Oh,
I mean,
do you drink after work?
Would you like,
no.
No,
you didn't.
because if you do,
then you don't stop.
There were,
there's a bunch of bars right by that
courthouse.
But imagine you were just wanting to
escape.
Yeah.
Well you just want to booze it up.
Well because the thing is,
as a defense attorney,
you're going to get your ass handed to
you so many fucking times that if I
drank one time for every time,
I didn't like what a judge decided,
I would have been dead seven ago.
Did
you get high?
No,
he didn't do nothing.
No.
Just went home pot pies and dealt with
it.
Yup.
Fuck man.
I went out on the weekends.
And you did stand up and you started
doing standup while you were an
attorney.
Yeah.
Well I've never seen you stand up dude.
But you're a smart guy so I can't
imagine you would suck.
I'm terrible.
Are you?
No.
Okay.
Yeah,
I didn't think you would.
And uh,
talking to at the comedy store was very
fun,
so I'm glad we did this man.
We just did a two and a half hours of a
breakdown of the criminal justice system
here,
thought and especially the criminal
justice system there and outside of
Madison,
Wisconsin.
And so,
um,
how long have you been doing standup
now?
Uh,
seven years,
I think.
Enjoying it.
Yeah.
It's Super Fun.
And what brought you to the store?
Uh,
well I was in Wisconsin,
but I moved here in January of last
year.
And honestly,
I really like pauly shore.
No,
no.
Like I was a kid in the 80s,
so when I would see Sam kinison on TV
and pauly shore on TV and everybody on
tv like it,
oh,
it always wound its way back to the
store.
Like pauly shore's first album is I
think recorded at the comedy store and
you can hear Ron,
Jeremy and uh,
Gary Coleman in the background.
Like it's nuts and like
laugh factory doesn't hire comics,
you know,
an Improv.
Is it like the store is kind of an icon.
And I worked in comedy clubs before,
so I was like,
hey.
Also the reality of it is like the
potluck is so hard to get on that Monday
night potluck and I had signed up every
single Monday for six months and I
hadn't gotten on once.
And then,
uh,
they,
they put out a list saying they're going
to do auditions for the new door guys.
So I signed up for it so that I could
get on the potluck.
But then it just went really well.
Wow.
Cause I just six months raise.
Yeah.
I just wanted to get up on the potluck
and signing up for the audition for the
job was the only way to do it.
Yeah.
You definitely seem overqualified to be
a door guy.
Yeah.
I liked the door guys.
It's a great gig.
Yeah.
But I'm saying you're,
how old are you?
36 yeah.
See Most door guys look 2122
they're getting older now.
Yup.
Guam is in his forties.
Uh,
hormones is 56 by the look of him.
He fucking loves 56.
It is a special place though,
isn't it?
I mean,
and you are a,
you've been an employee there during the
golden age.
I think there's the golden age.
Like the other night it was Joey Diaz,
Bill Burr,
Dama rare,
crystally Leah,
me and someone else on the show.
Someone else.
Oh,
Ali Wong.
She was on another one.
Those are different show.
It was just,
it
was insanity.
Yeah.
I was like sitting back watching all
these people and I was like,
this is the crazy,
I've never seen a lineup help.
Ron White was the other one.
Yeah.
I'm like,
I've never seen a lineup like this.
This isn't,
this lineup is,
it's insane.
Yeah.
Just murderer's row.
Oh,
well,
Joey Dee,
I don't want to say what the bid is
about,
but he's got this new bits he's doing
now.
It's is it?
It's just like it all the years that
I've been seen standup comedy and doing
it,
I just never have seen a club like this
or it's on fire right now.
Every night is sold out.
Crowds are insane.
Yeah.
It's really weird,
man.
It's a really weird,
here's another one.
This is from Thursday.
Yeah.
Okay.
Bobby Lee.
Tom Papa,
Bobby Lee,
Eliza crystally,
me,
Jessel neck,
Ron White,
Andrew Santinello,
Joey Diaz,
Donnelle Rawlings,
Jesus Christ,
and on and on and on.
Fuck man.
Jimmy Schubert's going to go.
What didn't you see me?
Nick Youssef is going to go,
what do you see me,
Dave Taylor.
I know.
Skakel me.
I could really read the whole list,
but it's an amazing lineup of known and
unknown.
Yeah.
I mean the guy in the second to last
spot created one of the shows on NBC
that's gone into its third season and
the guy who's going dead last to had a
movie on comedy central.
Like it's,
yeah,
that's tom embarrassed though.
He's an icon Stephan situation.
Like he belongs in that late,
late spot.
What I'm saying,
it's like that's how fucking pack the
lineup is insane.
Yeah.
But it's not just that,
it's also the vibe because of the fact
that the store hires all comedians like
yourself and like all these other ones
that work there.
It's like everybody is one of us.
You know,
and many guys have gone from being in
the position of being a doorman or work
in the cover booth or what have you to
being like Ari Shaffir perfect example.
Duncan trussell perfect example.
You know that have gone on during the
time that I've known him went from
starting out to being like super
headliners on the road.
Like yeah,
it's fascinating.
So there's no clubs like that where the
employees become the star attraction.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's,
It's the only one.
It's the only club that has like a true
farm system.
Right?
Yeah.
Especially in the fact that that farm
system exists in Hollywood.
And granted it's not,
it's not that easy to get into is you
can attest and it took six months of
nose to fucking the lineup is just,
there's just too many people that want
to become comics now,
isn't it?
Was not like that before,
by the way.
No,
I know when to get up every week before
those to it.
When I started in Madison in 2000
whenever there was like eight people,
eight comics,
and then when I left,
there's 60 then that would sign up for
the funniest comedian and Madison every
single year.
Whoa.
So yeah,
it's booming and I mean,
but under noon it's booming and quality
as well because there's an aspect of
storm and drawing.
Like there's only so many spots.
So these people have to be better.
Like these 60,
like you start now,
you got to know how you are the best and
why not try to be the best.
Why not try to fucking smoke that shit.
Like crush it for three minutes.
Like why half acid?
Like it used to be able to,
well,
even if they didn't want to have facet,
it's like,
it's not that they were half ass it and
it's like their standards got raised.
Like you see like roast battles,
perfect example of that.
I mean how many people courage at
Rosebank.
Oh yeah.
That you've never heard of it before and
you know,
they're writing ridiculously funny jokes
and crushing each other.
Yeah.
And they're coming up and they're
hungry.
There's a lot of them.
Competition.
Yeah.
It's a fun time,
man.
Yeah,
it's a really fun time.
So,
uh,
listen man,
thanks for doing this.
I appreciate you coming down on the
beautiful 4th of July.
Happy Independence Day.
You fucks.
And um,
you can catch Mike Schmidt on twitter.
Your twitter handle is the Shinola,
the Shinola.
It's linked on my,
uh,
my twitter page as well with Mike's
name.
And,
uh,
if you see a Mike at the comedy store,
I've come by,
say hi.
I'm all the fall guy,
man.
All right.
Thanks everybody.
Be Back tomorrow.
Oh,
Brennan shop is going to be here.
We're going to break down UFC 200,
which is this weekend.
Holla,
right?
Yeah.